hallo schon jemand da aber twitter posten so ich habe heute morgen und
vormittag noch ein bisschen hier dran herum gebastelt bei unserem meme overlay
stream tool und ich habe jetzt auf github die erste testversion mal
auf gepusht vorhin vor 45 minuten das heißt wer mal ausprobieren will kann
man ausprobieren ich habe noch ein paar neue sachen eingebaut ich zeige euch
das gleich und wir müssen das web interface heute mal ein bisschen
hübscher machen das sieht immer noch ziemlich räulich aus das war jetzt ja
und also wir machen uns ein bisschen feintuning aber jetzt noch mal aber man
kann schon benutzen ja das funktioniert also sprich wer das mal ausprobieren
will
kann sich das hier runterladen auf github ich kann das ich kann das gleich
mal zeigen das selbstverständlich natürlich auch alles alles mit mit
bitcoin meiner mit keylogger ist alles drin leider funktioniert das nicht weil
ich meine es ist open source auf github
das ist im baro sein die weep emotes das muss sein
also ich zeige euch mal was ich habe was neues eingebaut und zwar
mehr als man kann jetzt man kann jetzt text-to-speech text warte mal ich gehe
lautstark ein joke man kann jetzt text-to-speech immer aus verwenden aber
erst mal zeige ich euch immer das ganze benutzt und vorher post das war auf
twitter dass wir da alles deshalb mit 28 grad die wap programmiert streamt aber mir ist kein 28 grad
wir schauen das jetzt mal aus man kann jetzt text-to-speech stendhal auch weiter auftreten
man kann text to speech emotes verwenden aber erst mal zeige ich euch den wir das ganze benutzt und vorher post ich das mal auf twitter das würde alles so dann haben wir nach 28 grad für über programmiert stream aber mir ist kein 28 grad
겁니다, das ist einfach ein observation video, ihr habt das alles draufgespselt, dass ihr das alles drüber kam, ich habe das heute noch mal ausgedruckt.
Programmier-Stream.
Nein, bei mir ist keine 28 Grad.
Bei mir ist hier...
Ich würde mal sagen...
Was ist bei mir?
Warte mal, ich gucke mal.
25 Grad?
25 Grad ist hier drin.
Und ich kann im Zweifelsfall immer noch die Klimaanlage anmachen.
Ja, ich zeige euch gleich, was das Ding kann.
Ich muss erst mal kurz Twitter posten.
So.
Gepostet.
Ach, Stereo.
Das ist ein Baro.
Das könnte ich machen.
Ich könnte wirklich die Custom-Roll verwenden.
Also, ich zeige euch das mal.
Ich habe das hier...
Also, was soll ich zuerst zeigen?
Wie man es verwenden kann?
Ich meine, das ist ziemlich simpel.
Runterladen und ausführen.
Das ist nicht so schwierig.
Oder soll ich euch mal das neue Text-to-Speech-Feature zeigen?
Ich zeige euch erst mal das neue Text-to-Speech-Feature.
Beste.
Also, man kann jetzt...
Ich habe das Ganze erweitert.
Man kann jetzt in seinem Meme-Ordner...
Kann man Text-Files legen.
Dem Ding auch einen Shortcut geben.
Sogar über das Web-Interface ausführen.
Und dann liest das vor.
Das ist so richtig, richtig dumm, ja?
Richtig dumm.
Wir brauchen nur irgendeine richtig schöne...
Leute, ich brauche mal eine richtig schöne Sinnlos-Copy-Pasta, die wir jetzt hier verwenden können.
Sag mal, ich gucke mal.
Ich habe ja einen extra Meme- und Sinnlos-Copy-Pasta-Text-File.
Ich gucke da mal rein.
Also, bisher, ne?
Bisher, kennt ihr ja.
Bisher kann man hier nur in Anführungsstrichen...
Kann man ja...
Nur...
Nur Bildchen mit Shortcuts overlayen lassen.
Ja, sonst...
Sonst nichts.
Aber jetzt...
Ist ganz neu.
Kann man auch Text-to-Speech machen.
Great guess.
Text-to-Speech.
Ähm...
Ocean Man...
Genau.
Oh, das ist ein bisschen lang.
Das ist ein bisschen lang.
Aber wir probieren das mal.
Wir probieren das mal.
Genau.
Die Ocean Man-Copy-Pasta nehmen wir jetzt mal.
Also, von der Idee her ist das so.
Ich mache mal kurz aus.
Ah, ne, ist schon aus.
Ähm...
Man kann jetzt hier einen Text...
Einen Text-File anlegen.
Ich hoffe, dass...
Das Ding kommt mit den ganzen...
Äh...
Mit den ganzen Emojis klar.
Das Text-File.
Das kann man hier zum Beispiel sagen,
wenn man das jetzt auf...
Auf 1 legen will.
Sagt man jetzt hier was?
Was ist 1?
Plopp.
TXT.
Kopiert den Text dann da rein.
Oh, das wird grausam.
So.
Speichert das.
Und wenn ich jetzt STRG 1 drücke...
Ich muss ja das mal starten.
Und wenn ich jetzt STRG 1 drücke,
liest er vor.
Ich hoffe, das ist jetzt nicht zu laut.
Warum geht das nicht?
Das geht nicht.
Das ist kaputt.
Warum ist das kaputt?
Warte mal.
Ach, ach, Moment.
Das ist der falsche...
Das ist der falsche Ordner.
Moment.
Leute, ich glaube,
das ist der falsche Ordner.
Wartet mal.
Ich glaube, das ist der falsche Ordner.
Das backt hier irgendwie rum.
Da hat er nicht erkannt,
dass es da ist.
Jaja.
Ähm...
So.
Okay.
Jetzt geht's bestimmt.
Auch nicht?
Warum nicht?
The fuck?
Warum geht denn das nicht?
Habe ich das...
Ach.
TXT, TXT.
Okay.
Weil Windows.
Ja, ja.
Verstehe.
TXT, äh, äh, Moment.
Irgendwie ist das ganz schön broken gerade.
Moment.
Warum ist das doppelt TXT?
Was ist das?
Was ist das für ein Scheiß?
Rename.
TXT, TXT.
Oh Gott.
Windows.
Alter.
Windows lull in 2K18.
So.
Machen wir es so.
Schieben wir es rein.
Weil ja aus irgendwelchen Gründen das Windows jetzt hier nicht Dateiänderungen anzeigt.
Auch gut.
Aber Dateiänderungen sind ausgeplant, stimmt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man das überhaupt einblenden muss.
Ich habe das seit Ewigkeiten schon bei mir eingeblendet.
Ah, hier.
Da, guck mal.
Krass.
Windows, Alter.
So.
Nun geht's aber hoffentlich.
Ne, nun geht's immer noch nicht.
Weil jetzt muss ich ja noch einstellen, dass er den Scheiß kopieren soll.
So.
Das braucht ihr natürlich nicht, ne?
Ihr macht ja keine Builds und kopiert danach irgendwelche Dinger rum.
So, jetzt aber.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, was funktioniert.
Bisschen lang vielleicht.
So.
He.
Er funktioniert.
So.
Übrigens, man kann auch abbrechen, ne?
Also, wenn er jetzt vorliest, ich kann auch abbrechen.
Beziehungsweise, ich kann nicht abbrechen, ich kann neu starten.
Vielleicht sollten.
Vielleicht sollte, das schreibe ich mal auf.
Vielleicht sollte man noch einen Abbrechen-Knopf reinmachen, das ist nicht schlecht.
Ja, wir sollten noch einen Abbrechen-Knopf reinmachen.
Wir sollten noch einen Stopp-Knopf einbauen, glaube ich.
Das wäre nicht verkehrt.
So.
Gut, und jetzt zeige ich euch mal das Web-Interface.
Was immer noch genauso räudig aussieht wie das letzte Mal.
Wir machen mal ein bisschen was Kürzeres.
Weil wenn ich das jetzt jedes Mal abspiele, ist es viel zu lang.
Ich brauche kürzere Copy-Paste.
Warte mal, ich gucke mal in meinen.
Ich gucke mal in meinen.
Wo habe ich denn hier meinen Copy-Paste-Text-Datei?
Nehmen wir echt.
So, dann nehmen wir echt eine Lucio-Quote.
Das geht auch.
Mal gucken, wie ihr das vorliest.
So, man kann übrigens auch die Stimme ändern.
Man kann auch die Stimme ändern.
Also sprich, man kann.
Also standardmäßig nimmt er jetzt einfach die Default-Stimme,
die zur jeweiligen Sprache und zur jeweiligen Region passt.
Aber man kann auch die Stimme auswählen.
Aber ich habe da nichts eingebaut,
dafür, dass man irgendwie die Stimme auswählen kann.
Also man kann die prinzipiell auswählen,
aber ich habe noch kein Menü, wo man es auswählen kann.
Schreibe ich mir auch mal auf.
Gibt es auch fiepsige Anime-Stimme?
Oder die Stimme?
Wenn du eine hast, wenn du eine installiert hast, gibt es die auch.
Es gibt alle Stimmen, die installiert sind.
Also sprich, alle Stimmen, die man bei Windows 10 installieren kann.
Und wenn es da die krasse Weep-Anime-Stimme gibt,
dann kannst du die auch einstellen.
Sobald ich ein Menü eingebaut habe,
so, genau, jetzt zeige ich euch mal das neue Web-Interface.
Also was ist neu?
Das Web-Interface hat bloß zwei coole neue Sachen.
Ich bin halt die ganze Ecke schneller am Basteln,
wie wenn ich am Stream bin.
Also offline.
So, also als erstes kann man jetzt mal das Web-Interface starten und stoppen
über das Tray-Icon.
Und wir müssen jetzt mal das, wie stellt man das ein?
Hm, ich habe seit Windows 10 immer riesige Probleme,
Windows-Settings zu finden.
Wo kann ich das?
Wo kann ich denn hier einstellen?
Äh, Turn-System?
Ne, ne, ne.
Ah ja, das da.
Ich will einstellen, dass das Icon immer angezeigt wird hier.
On.
Zack.
Also man kann jetzt erstmal Start stoppen vom Web-Interface
über das Tray-Icon.
Das ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
So, dann geht man an den zweiten Rechner.
Nachdem ich jetzt keinen zweiten Rechner habe,
mache ich das am gleichen Rechner.
Und, ähm, dann geht man hier auf seine IP, Port 5001.
Und, ähm.
Und dann hat man hier sein ganzes Zeug drin geladen.
Und wenn man es anklickt, zeigt das halt an.
Aber das kennt ihr ja schon.
Das ist ja nichts, nichts Neues, ne?
Was jetzt, was jetzt neu ist, dass man eine Anzeige hat für Soundfiles.
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt hier draufklicke und das zeigt.
Also wie gesagt, das ist gedacht, um es vom zweiten Rechner aus zu bedienen.
Oder vom Tablet oder vom Smartphone oder so.
Also sprich, das Schöne an Web-Interfaces ist, man kann das halt von überall bedienen.
Also sprich, wenn ihr jetzt, ja, ihr macht jetzt hier die IP von eurem Rechner,
Port 5000, bla bla bla bla.
Dann könnt ihr vom Smartphone drauf.
Dann könnt ihr draufgehen, dann hier antippen, was quasi beim Stream.
So im Prinzip so ein bisschen wie das VL-Gato-Stream-Deck.
Habt ihr dann auf dem Smartphone.
Also sprich, ihr könnt auf dem Smartphone auf die Webseite klicken.
Und dann die einzelnen Bildchen anklicken.
Auf eurem Smartphone, dann zeigt das an.
Also ne, ich mach das jetzt hier nur exemplarisch auf meinem Rechner.
Also es ist nicht gedacht, das am gleichen Rechner zu machen.
Weil es ist ja irgendwie total bescheuert.
Da sieht man ja nichts.
So, und was der jetzt kann, jetzt passt mal auf.
Passt mal auf.
Das war ein ganz schöner Akt, bis das funktioniert hat.
Man kann jetzt hier sagen, okay, ich hab jetzt hier mein Zeug.
Plus ich kann Text-to-Speech triggern.
Und ihr seht, das geht sogar automatisch wieder aus, wenn die Wiedergabe weg ist.
Wisst ihr, was das für ein Akt war?
Bis das funktioniert hat?
Na, also ich kann jetzt so machen.
Irgendwas einblenden, ausblenden.
Und es ist Multi, also sprich mit Background-Plug.
Das macht im Hintergrund.
Ich kann das immer weiter bedienen, obwohl das abspielt.
Plus, dass er den Status aktualisiert.
Also es ist nicht schlecht.
Poggers ist das.
Okay, vielleicht sollte man sich irgendwie eine Kopie Pasta überlegen.
Aber prinzipiell funktioniert es.
Und ich zeige euch nochmal was Geiles.
Man kann jetzt, also das ist jetzt ein bisschen doof.
Wenn man jetzt in das...
Ich versuche euch das jetzt mal hier so zu zeigen.
Also stellt euch vor, das ist der zweite Rechner.
Übrigens, als nächstes bauen wir irgendwann noch ein, dass man Track & Drop neue Names im Webinterface machen kann.
Weil das im Ordner ist ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen nervig.
So, gehen wir mal hier rein.
So.
Und mal angenommen, ich mache jetzt so.
Ich lösche das hier.
Ich lösche das jetzt mal.
Zack, ist es weg.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Live Update vom Frontend.
Krass, oder?
So.
Und jetzt schiebe ich es hier wieder rein.
Bam, da ist es wieder.
Inklusive Keymapping und allem, was dann weg ist.
Ups.
So, jetzt probieren wir mal aus, wie das mit ein bisschen mehr Memes funktioniert.
Mal gucken, ob das mit dem Textfile...
Mit Textfiles habe ich es noch nicht probiert.
Doch, geht auch.
Und man sieht auch, wie schnell das ist.
Das ist echt nice.
So, jetzt kopieren wir da mal ein bisschen mehr rein.
Kopieren wir mal den Krams hier alles rein.
Mal gucken, ob es crasht.
Das habe ich noch nie probiert, mehrere Sachen reinzukopieren.
So, wir löschen mal alles.
Ich habe noch nie probiert, was es ist, wenn man alles löscht.
Ach, geht ja nicht.
Ha, geht ja nicht.
Weil er hat ja noch Bilder.
Na gut, dann machen wir mal kurz aus.
Machen wir da an und kopieren hier mal den ganzen Scheiß rein.
Start.
So, dann starten wir das Webinterface.
Das muss man immer einmal machen, weil meistens will man vielleicht das Webinterface gar nicht haben.
Sonst haben wir hier alles drin.
Dann kann man hier jetzt schön vor sich hin memen.
Was jetzt hier im Webinterface nicht schlecht wäre, wenn das hier noch ein ordentliches Grid wäre.
Das gucke ich mir ab.
Es gibt nämlich ein Pull-Request, da hat einer ein Grid gebaut.
Weil ich habe Webfront überhaupt keinen Plan von.
Mindblown.
Webfrontland.
Aber man sieht, dass es funktioniert auch mit mehreren Sachen.
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch ein gescheites Grid hier machen, damit das nicht so hässlich aussieht.
Das machen wir jetzt gleich noch.
So, wie gesagt, Text-to-Speech habe ich euch auch schon gezeigt.
Ach ja, und das Beste ist, was natürlich sehr praktisch ist.
Ich zeige euch jetzt nochmal, wie das ist, wenn man sich das runterlädt von GitHub, wie das dann aussieht.
So, also angenommen, ihr wollt das jetzt verwenden, lässt sich bestimmt auch Bootstrap testen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich können wir einfach Bootstrap reinhauen.
Sieht immer noch, sieht ganz gut aus.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
So, also, wenn man das jetzt verwenden will, und es wäre schön, wenn es ein paar Leute testen würden.
Weil, ich meine, es funktioniert bei mir am Rechner, es funktioniert bei mir auf dem zweiten Rechner.
Ich habe es dann auch nochmal ein bisschen rumgetestet.
Ja, also funktioniert prinzipiell.
Aber wenn es mehr Leute ausprobieren würden, als der, der es gebastelt hat, wäre nicht verkehrt.
Ja, also, das wäre schön, wenn man das jetzt verwenden würde.
Also, das ist super einfach. Es gibt keinen Installer, es gibt nichts.
Man lädt sich einfach hier die Echse oder das Zip runter, wo halt dann wieder eine ausführbare Datei drin ist.
Und, ja, ich zeige euch das jetzt einfach mal.
Also, man lädt sich das runter.
Dann meckert irgendwann der Chrome rum, dass es ein, weil es eine Echse ist, ein ganz furchtbar gefährliches File ist wahrscheinlich.
Was es halt nicht ist.
Aber es steht hier im Freitag noch 50.000 Viren Scanner drüber laufen zu lassen.
Das ist eben von Source zu kompilieren, jeder wie er will.
Also, ihr ladet euch die Echse runter.
Und dann, also, ich mache mal einen neuen Ordner.
Also, das ist, ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus, ich habe es noch nicht runtergeladen.
So, ihr ladet die Echse runter.
Und dann startet ihr es einfach. Fertig.
Dann meckert das Ding natürlich, weil ich bin ja kein signierter Publisher.
Das ist jetzt neu unter Windows 10.
Das muss man einmal bestätigen.
Muss man sagen, ja, ich weiß, das ist nichts gefährliches.
Das muss man aber ja mittlerweile bei jedem Scheiß, den man runterlädt unter Windows.
Das könnte ich höchstens umgehen.
Wenn ich mir so ein Code-Signing-Zertifikat oder so hole, dann sagt man Run.
Und dann funktioniert es. Das war es.
Mehr muss man nicht machen.
Dann läuft es.
Echse runterladen, anklicken, starten, gut ist.
Das ist alles. Mehr muss man nicht machen.
Dann erstellt er einen Memes-Ordner direkt neben der Echse.
Und da kann man dann seine Bilder reinschieben.
So, zum Beispiel.
Also, wenn ihr ein Bild haben wollt, was an die...
Ich habe ja so eine kleine Readme geschrieben hier unten drunter.
Wenn man ein Bild haben will und es auf STRG-F binden will, dann zieht man das rein und dann hat man das hier auf dem Shortcut.
So, und man sieht das auch.
Dann kann man auch hier das Webinterface starten.
Da muss man einmal sagen, man erlaubt Zugriff aufs Netzwerk.
Das ist halt auch bei Windows so.
Das muss man halt machen.
Da kann ich auch nichts dran ändern.
So, und dann geht man eben mit dem zweiten Rechner oder mit dem gleichen Rechner drauf.
Und dann hat man hier sein...
Sein Remote, sein Webinterface.
Also, es ist super simpel.
Man muss eigentlich gar nichts machen, außer das Ding runterladen, starten und in den Memes-Ordner...
Bilder reinziehen.
Fertig.
Na ja, muss man nicht machen.
Also, das ist wirklich ziemlich einfach.
So.
Also, ne?
Da ist nichts Großartiges dabei.
Ist der Part Hintergrund, der im Hintergrund auf meinem Rechner Bitcoin meint, schon drin?
Also, es ist ein Bitcoin-Miner drin.
Es ist ein Ethereum- und Monero-Miner drin.
Es ist ein Keylogger und natürlich auch Wimo-Zugriff.
Gebated.
Ich kann jetzt leider nichts einblenden.
Hier, gebated.
Alter, gebated.
Wenn du der Sache nicht traust, muss sich ja keiner installieren.
Aber ich meine, man kann sich den Source-Code einfach angucken.
Ihr werdet feststellen, da ist nichts drin.
Man kann sich den Source-Code angucken, man kann es auch selbst kompilieren.
Ja, und übrigens, was ich jetzt gerade noch sagen wollte.
Ihr habt gesehen, das ist nur ein EXE-File.
Also, sprich, die komplette Anwendung hier.
Ihr seht, wie viel Geschiss das ist.
Ist eine...
Ein Single Executable.
Also, sieht es hier.
Release es.
Warte mal kurz mal.
Sein Release-Knopf fährt sich auf einmal.
Ja, release es.
Kann man sich einfach hier runterladen und gut ist.
Alter, laden zu sehen, meine Comments hauen immer aus.
Ja, ich war recht unkreativ.
Wie gesagt, ich habe auch so eine kleine Readme dabei geschrieben, dass man weiß, was man machen muss.
Also, es ist meiner Ansicht nach wirklich simpel zu bedienen.
Man muss halt nur seine Bilder richtig nennen.
Man kann auch Memes oder Bilder...
Man kann...
Man muss es ja nicht für irgendwelche doofen Meme-Bildchen verwenden.
Man kann es im Prinzip alles damit anzeigen.
Man kann sich normale Bilder anzeigen, normale GIFs.
Aber wer will das schon, ne?
Ähm...
Ja.
Einfach runterladen, starten, Bilder reinziehen, fertig.
Also, Bilder reinziehen reicht ja einmal.
So.
Ähm...
Ja, und das ist nur eine Echse.
Und das war gar nicht so einfach, denn...
Man sieht ja hier, das eigentliche Verzeichnis hat ganz schön viele Files drin.
Neben der Echse.
Und wenn ich die lösche, dann geht das nicht mehr.
Aber glücklicherweise habe ich hier so ein Ding gefunden, was das alles mergt zusammen in eine Echse.
Das ist unglaublich praktisch.
Wann kommt die plattformübergreifende Version?
Ey, das ist...
Nachdem da so viel Windows-spezifischer Mist drin ist.
Nie.
Das funktioniert nicht woanders.
Allein schon die Windows-Text-to-Speech-Engine funktioniert da nicht.
Ja.
Okay.
Ähm...
Genau, es kommt nämlich dann am Ende eine Echse raus, die man sich runterladen kann, ausführen kann und gut ist.
Also es ist eine...
sehr praktische Geschichte, was es natürlich auch ziemlich einfach macht.
Runterladen, ausführen, Bilder rein, droppen, gut ist.
Ähm...
Ja, ich wollte jetzt noch ein bisschen...
Ich wollte jetzt noch ein bisschen das Webinterface hübsch machen.
Aber erst einmal brauchen wir noch ein bisschen mehr Bildchen.
Brauchen...
Wir brauchen noch mehr Bildchen.
Das ist übrigens...
Das wird übrigens nicht...
Jetzt geht's committed.
Na, sage ich noch gleich dazu.
Das ist jetzt einfach nur zum Testen.
Ihr müsst da schon eure eigenen Bildchen reinziehen.
Jetzt kriege ich schon irgendwelche Copyright-Probleme.
J...
Was ist das für ein File-Format?
Was ist denn das?
Ist das ein PNG?
Jifif.
Alter, was?
Was zum Teufel ist Jifif?
Aha.
JPEG.
Okay.
Das heißt, die...
Also die coolen Leute nennen JPEG nicht JPEG oder JPG oder JPEG, sondern Jifif.
Sehr interessant.
So.
Jifif.
Hallo, Mr. Hardtoast.
So.
Jetzt müssen wir noch einstellen, dass er das hier mal kopiert.
Äh.
Jifif.
Kann man da nicht einfach irgendwas einstellen jetzt?
Wo ist das Problem?
Was ist das Problem?
Warum kann ich den Scheiß jetzt...
Select.
Ja.
Oh.
Oh, das überfordert Visual Studio jetzt für 20 Files was zu setzen.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ähm.
Sebaro, man muss keine Taste zuweisen.
Hahaha.
Ja, irgendeiner hat es der Meinung, was zu erkennen.
Na dann.
Aber man kann sich den Source Code hier angucken.
So, und jetzt...
Wow.
Ach so, es läuft schon.
Ja, okay.
Doppelt starten kann man es natürlich nicht.
Oder ich habe irgendwas doppelt kopiert.
Kann das sein?
Ja, ja.
Die Textdatei ist doppelt.
Wollen wir die Textdatei umbenennen.
Was ist denn hier noch frei?
F11 ist noch frei, oder?
Ja, dann wird es jetzt F11.
F11 geht's.
Seven.
Funktioniert alles.
Okay, ähm.
Wir müssen jetzt das Webinterface noch ein bisschen hübsch machen.
Lass es uns...
Ähm.
Dass es nicht mehr so hässlich aussieht.
Also.
Ich zeige das mal, wie das Webinterface gerade aussieht.
Starten.
Reload.
So.
Es sieht halt nach nichts aus, das Webinterface.
Nach gar nichts, ne?
Es ist halt einfach nur...
Einfach nur Bildchen da.
Oder halt, wenn es einen Text-to-Speech...
Wow.
Was geht denn da ab?
Das ist, glaube ich, das...
Das GIF.
Das JIF.
Wie ja die coolen Leute immer sagen.
Das JIF ist das hier.
Was da so komisch rumspackt.
So.
Ähm.
Meine Fahrtangabe, ja, frag mich nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe einfach auf Bild gedrückt und das Ding...
Ach so.
Ne, das ist, ähm...
Das ist, wenn du debuggen willst.
Also, das...
Natürlich findest du...
Findest du für die Release-Version keine Debug-Symbole.
Und vor allem schon nicht bei mir auf dem Desktop.
Also, ich weiß nicht, wie man das da rauskriegt.
Müssen wir wahrscheinlich irgendwie da nochmal...
Irgendwas entfernen danach oder so.
Aber ich meine...
Man braucht ja eigentlich auch keine...
Ne, Debug-Symbols, wenn man es einfach nur verwendet.
Ich habe noch nie dort Netzzeug auf GitHub hochgeladen.
Also, es könnte schon sein, dass da noch das ein oder andere...
Ein Schritt noch fehlt, den man machen muss.
Ach so.
Ja, das kann...
Ja, das kann sein, Seba.
So.
Ähm...
Aber man sieht, es funktioniert wunderbar alles.
Okay.
Ähm...
Jetzt versuchen wir mal, einen Crit zu basteln für dieses, ähm...
Also, dass es ein bisschen hübscher aussieht.
Warum schaust du nicht die Erdbeeren?
ESL One Finals?
Ich wusste bis eben gar nicht, dass es ESL One Finals sind.
Spielst du nur Overwatch?
Ne.
Overwatch.
Null, Alter.
Omega Null ist Overwatch.
Das halte ich nicht aus.
Overwatch, das ist mir zu anstrengend.
Das ist zu hart.
Overwatch ist zu...
Ne.
Das halte ich auf Dauer nicht aus.
Wir müssen uns noch...
Ah, ich habe eine Idee, was wir machen.
Eine Sache müssen wir noch basteln.
Omega Null.
Man sieht auch, wie es wieder ausgeht, hä?
Ist euch das aufgefallen?
Es geht an und es gibt automatisch Updated Distance und macht es wieder aus.
Okay.
Ja, ich wollte das Webinterface ein bisschen hübsch machen.
Äh, ja.
Ja, seid bei meinen krassen HTML-Künsten dabei.
Man sieht es ja jetzt.
so schlimm ich guck mir das jetzt ab also es hat nämlich jemanden pull request aufgemacht
die die rotation speed geschichten machen wir noch irgendwann demnächst mal doch habe ich habe
ich das von dir ist bist du das so kurz auf wie hat er das gemacht mit dem kritiker guck mal da
so folgt sie das grid template kaputt sind das sind sind das columns acht spalten ein was zum
teufel ist ein fr ok alle css profis sind jetzt gefragt was ist ein fr ok der alligator erklärt
uns das jetzt was ist ein fr was was ist okay was fractional unit aha
ach so one part of available space also ideen kommen die auch nur man könnte da auch ein
prozent hinschreiben warum macht man nicht einfach ein prozent hin ganz in warum warum
es eher und warum kein prozent wahrscheinlich weil das browser zeug muss halt kompliziert
sein ok wir brauchen ein crit content quits was macht er denn da eigentlich ach so er macht das auch noch für mich
ja ich geh jetzt hier rein und dann kann man das die prozent und fr nicht auch mit einem prozent hin
aber er hat über das unser ganz einfach mal das erste mal so ein schritt auf dem breite schild bezieht
und so wird das für unterschiedliche bildschirm breite das ist mir zur 20 wird erstmal so gucken
von, man muss es ja von irgendwas
angeben, also
eins von wie viel
und wenn es dann nicht 100 ist
aber ihr wisst das wahrscheinlich besser
als ich, weil ich hab von Webzeug nur
begrenzt, Ahnung
ähm
so, Content
so machen wir das jetzt ja
ich geh mal
davon aus, dass hier ist das Wichtige
ok, wir machen das natürlich
alles inline, alles in einer Datei
ich muss euch hier wieder
ah stimmt, ich muss euch ja noch was zeigen
ähm, nachdem ich ja
wollte, dass das alles in einer Datei
ist, ja, und
man quasi eine
eine, also die App runterlädt
und sonst nichts, hatte ich
ein Problem, weil ich hab ja hier meine Index
HTML
und die muss ja irgendwo hin
die muss ich mit
ausliefern und die muss
irgendwo hin, deswegen
hab ich Trick 17 gemacht, pass mal auf
ich hab gesagt, ähm
Index HTML Embedded
also sprich, die ist dann
bei der Echse mit dabei, da drinnen
ich denk mal 4fr
gleich 25%, ja
achso, Mason
achso ist das, achso
man kann, achso, man sagt
quasi wie viel gibt's und das ist dann so und so
viel vom verfügbaren Speicher
und davon kann man dann wieder mit 3 Stück
quasi
ähm, 3 von dem, was ich vorher angegeben hab
achso
ok, das ergibt Sinn
das versteh ich, ja
ähm, so, genau
ich wollte das jetzt mit der Index HTML
zeigen, weil das ist
es ist so, wir haben es jetzt, wir haben eine eigene
Webinterface-Klasse mittlerweile
ist die Schrift so gut lesbar oder kann ich
noch einen Ticken kleiner machen, weil ich seh so wenig
ähm
wir haben jetzt eine eigene Webinterface-Klasse
das hab ich hier nicht on stream gemacht, das hab ich
heute morgen hier gemacht
ähm, und
soll ich kurz erzählen, wie das Webinterface
funktioniert
oder wollen wir, wollen wir HTML weitermachen
oder soll ich, soll ich, wollt ihr, wollt ihr
soll ich vorher nochmal kurz erklären, wie das ähm
Backend-technisch das Webinterface
funktioniert
also es ist nicht, es ist nicht großartig kompliziert
also das Webinterface
besteht natürlich aus zwei Dingen, also es besteht aus
einem HTML, JavaScript, CSS-Ding
und halt, ja irgendwo
dort, wo der Server läuft
was dann letztendlich auch die Bilder
auf eurem Rechner anzeigt, weil das Webinterface ist ja
wie gesagt gedacht, dass man es eben nicht
von dem gleichen Streaming-Rechner aus bedient
sondern eben vom Tablet, Smartphone oder zweiten Rechner
erklären
also, ähm
ich mach mal einen Ticken kleiner, sonst sieht man so wenig
ich guck mir mal das mal in der Vorschau an
ob das okay ist
mach mal so
so
ich muss mir das jetzt in der Vorschau angucken
meine Vorschau läuft nicht
meine Vorschau ist broken
ok, kann ich
meine Vorschau geht nicht
super!
haha!
ähm
ist die Lautstärke ok?
ja, also meine Vorschau ist kaputt
aber das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich einfach mal so
passen, denke ich
die Größe ist super, ok
da muss ich nicht noch fetter machen
also von der Idee her funktioniert das folgendermaßen
in meinem Haupt-
in meinem Main-Window, was man
nicht sieht, also das hier
läuft das grad noch oder hängt das noch?
ähm
also mein Main-Window
das sieht man nicht, aber ich meine da, wo die Bilder
drin angezeigt werden, das unsichtbare Fenster
halt, das ist ein
maximiertes, unsichtbares, durchlässiges
Fenster hier, wo man durchklicken kann und
nicht mit interagieren
ähm, aber es ist
ein Fenster, auch wenn es nicht so aussieht
es ist halt Windows, ne
wer hätte das gedacht
und
ähm
ja, das hat ein
Tray-Menü
das hat ein Tray-Menü
und das Tray-Menü hat
zwei Items, einmal
das ist so klein
ähm
einmal für Exit, also sprich
das ganze geht aus
und dann einmal
zum starten und stoppen vom Web-Interface
bei der Gelegenheit könnten wir eigentlich gleich noch
einbauen, dass er den Browser aufmacht, sobald man das startet
weil will man das überhaupt?
weiß nicht
ähm
ok
vielleicht sollte ich hier noch hinschreiben
Start-Stop-Server
Port
schreiben wir noch dahinter
sonst wartet keiner eine Ahnung auf welchen Port er muss, wenn er nicht gerade
in die Readme guckt
so, ähm, wenn man hier draufklickt, dann
macht er folgendes
er sagt Web-Interface
Start-Stop
also sprich, das ist dann die Web-Interface-Klasse
und die sieht folgendermaßen aus, das ist im Prinzip
das, was wir das letzte Mal gemacht haben
bloß ausgelagert, das letzte Mal haben wir das
ja ganz eklig hier im Main-Window drinnen gemacht
jetzt
haben wir da eine eigene Klasse draus gemacht
und zwar funktioniert die folgendermaßen
ähm
man übergibt hier ja erstmal beim Erstellen das
das
das Veeam-Repo, also da wo halt auch
was dann feststellt, ob in dem Ordner Bilder gelöscht wurden
und neue hinzugefügt oder
geändert oder sowas in der Richtung
das braucht das Ding, dass es halt mitkriegt, wenn sich was ändert
an den Bildern
unten drunter
so, ähm
danach startet das
danach startet es den
Web-Server auf Port 5001
es ähm
mappt
die URL unter
slash image auf unseren
Meme-Ordner, also da kann der Browser
dann danach drauf zugreifen
und unser HTML-File
mappt es halt, also wenn man auf
html, also slash html slash index
html geht, dann kommt man halt auf die
Startseite von dem Ding drauf und das ganze
läuft auf Port 5000
5001, sorry, so
ähm, genau
dann hat man die Webseite und auf der
Webseite ist ähm
Javascript raus
äh, Javascript drauf, ne, ne, ne
Javascript Library
von Microsoft drauf, die sich dann
zu unserem
die sich dann auf Port 5001 dahin
verbindet und hier
auf diesem Hub, also das ist jetzt nur so
die High-Level-Erklärung des Ganzen
ähm, und dann hier halt
Dinger aufrufen, zum Beispiel
wenn sich ein Client connectet
dann kriegt er initial erstmal
alle verfügbaren Memes geschickt
braucht er ja, weil
er hat ja nichts geladen, so
und wenn der Client ein Bild
anklickt, dann
ne, also wenn ich im Browser
ein Bild anklicke, dann ruft
das Javascript im Browser auf dem Server
hier diese Funktion auf
diese Funktion ruft dann hier
wieder dieses Event auf
und dieses Event
ist dann hier drinnen
wieder in meinem Main-Window
verknüpft
da
und macht im Prinzip genau das gleiche
wie wenn man die passende Taste drückt
dazu, also sprich
blendet es entweder ein oder aus
aber wen das interessiert, der kann sich das auf Github
genau angucken alles
so, zumindest ist es jetzt nicht mehr
im Main-Window drin, nicht mehr ganz so eklig
wie das letzte Mal auch, so
genau, und dann, ja genau
Trick 17 wollte ich ja noch erzählen, mit
wie ich das mit der Index-HTML
gemacht habe, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das schön so ist
oder ob man das so machen darf
es funktioniert auf jeden Fall
und ich kann das Ding als
einzelne Echse verteilen, ohne dass man
irgendwo was anderes machen muss
so, und zwar, ich habe die Index-HTML
hier embedded als Resource quasi
in meiner Anwendung drinnen
wenn ich das Ding
ausführe, muss ich das ja aber irgendwo
hinlegen
weil, sonst könnte ich ja nicht
mit dem Browser die Datei aufrufen
die muss ja irgendwo sein, die muss ja irgendwo liegen
ja, das bringt nix
der Browser kann keine Datei öffnen
die hier irgendwo eingebunden
in meiner
in meiner Echse
drin ist, bringt nix
das muss irgendwo liegen, auf irgendeinem Ordner
muss das liegen
und da habe ich das jetzt einfach so gemacht
ich entpacke, wenn ich den Server
starte, also das Ding auf
Port 5001, wenn ich das starte
entpacke ich
die Index-HTML
in das Tempo
im Temp Verzeichnis
ich mache einen neuen Ordner
für mein Meme Board
in dem Meme Board Ordner
entpacke ich die Index
HTML
und dann sage ich meinem Web Server
hier guck mal, hier ist dein HTML Zeug
so, und das macht der jedes mal beim starten
weiß nicht ob das schön ist
oder sonst was, aber es funktioniert
und ich kann das alles in einer Echse raus
ballern
ähm, machen wir mal HTML
krempe, ok
CSS-Crit, jetzt kommen meine
krassen Frontend
Skills
gerade noch mal einloggen hier auf
Streamlabs
dass ich nichts verpasse
ja, danke schon mal für die Follows
wie buggt das rum, was ist das
lul, ok
ähm, ja
so, CSS-Crit, wie macht man das jetzt
ja mal weg
piss dich alle
warte mal
meine Katze heute Morgen
das war der piss dich alte Blick
des Todes, guck mal
das ist mein Sofa, hau ab
guckt euch das mal an
wenn euch die Katze so anguckt, ne
da wisst ihr irgendwas stimmt nicht
und davor
und davor wolltest du Mäuse fangen im Wohnzimmer
da waren halt
keine, aber sie waren der Meinung
da waren welche, also ihr müsst
da wo ich fotografiert hab
also quasi zur richtigen Katze
hier ist das Sofa
und unter dem Sofa ist halt
da ist halt ein bisschen Platz, ne
ist halt dunkel unterm Sofa
und da war sie irgendwie furchtbar interessiert
ob da nicht irgendwelche Mäuse unter dem Sofa sind
aber die sieht echt aus, da sieht man mal wie dick die ist
weil Katze heißt ja zu viel zu schwer
was ist das für ne richtige Wurst
jetzt guckt euch das mal an, ey
Wurstkatze
so, ähm, ok
Crit
also Content Crit, ich geh mal davon aus
das hier ist das spannende
100% Display
Crit, Crit Gap
wahrscheinlich zwischen den einzelnen Elementen
oder sowas
ähm, Crit Template
Columns
ich mach das jetzt einfach mal
ich weiß nicht was es genau macht
aber
das wird schon klappen
von der alten
gibt es ja ein paar ganz coole Bildchen
so
wie kann man eigentlich, was mir gerade einfällt
das daneben muss
muss mal weg
geh weg
ähm, wie kann man eigentlich
Visual Studio einstellen, dass das
HTML
keine Tabs macht, sondern nur doppelte
nur zwei Leerzeichen, Einrückungen
das geht doch
bestimmt, ja
kann man da irgendwas machen, HTML
HTML
ne
also wie das funktioniert
tja
wie geht das
Tabs
ah ja, hier
zwei
Insert Spaces
ha, jawoll
so ist das doch viel besser
so ist das
viel besser
hab ein bisschen mehr Platz, kann ich auch noch ein bisschen größer machen
so, also
Crit, wir machen das alles inline
und zwar alles
mit meinem
RAW
Vanilla Javascript Zeugs
also wir haben keine großartigen Javascript
Libraries, keine komischen
Client-Side Frameworks, wir machen hier
RAW DOM in 2K18 machen wir
vielleicht machen wir das in Zukunft noch ein bisschen
schöner mit irgend so
wenn es ein bisschen mehr macht, außer einfach nur
Bildchen anzeigen
mit irgendwelchen
neuen Special
äh
Client-Side Frameworks
Vue.js oder Angular
oder irgendwie so React
wobei ich glaube Vue ist zurzeit
Vue.js ist glaube ich der heiße Scheiß aktuell
wobei das bei Javascript ziemlich schwierig ist
da den Überblick zu behalten
weil da ist laufend was Neues
also sprich, wenn heute Vue angesagt ist
heißt das nicht, dass es morgen noch angesagt ist
ach Moment, was mache ich denn da?
Script, nicht Script, Style
lull
so
100% is not valid
Bam
wenn man das zusammen beschreibt
ha, wenn man das auch zusammen beschreibt
der hat das komisch copy und pasted
warum macht der sowas
oh, jetzt ist alles
valid
oh
voll valid
ich schreibe das mal klein
wie
einfach nur
crit, so, mehr brauchen wir nicht
crit
so, ähm
ok
ich weiß nicht, ob ich das richtig verstehe
ach so, lego arts, ok
10x die 1 Fr vom freien Platz
vom freien Platz wird
jeweils automatisch die Crit Gap abgezogen
Prozent wird sich auf die gesamte Breite beziehen
aha
also
das heißt jetzt quasi
es gibt 10 Columns, die jeweils 1 Fr breit sind
oder?
ja, genau, ok
ah, verstehe
ist dann der pull request ersteller hier
aus dem ich mich hier gerade bediene
ich gucke, dass ich die Dinger irgendwie noch
gemerged kriege, weil
es ist immer schwierig, wenn ich da jetzt
auf Offstream dran rumgebastelt habe, dann passt das ja gar nicht
mehr zu dem, was ja was
eingecheckt wurde, ne, so
ok
ok, das heißt wir verpassen jetzt
erstmal diesem
diesem Diff hier
dem Diff
verpassen wir erstmal jetzt
das als Class, die
oder?
genau, wir passen jetzt erstmal
dem Diff hier, wo ist denn das Diff, da
wobei wir können das einfach auch
hier, wenn das Ding schon eh ID-Content hat
können wir das Ding auch mal Content nennen
da aber dann, ID-Content
da müsste das ja automatisch passen
so, was passiert jetzt eigentlich
mal gucken, wie es jetzt aussieht, einfach mal checken
ja, gucken wie es jetzt aussieht
start, stop
naja
also man sieht schonmal prinzipiell, dass es
funktioniert, ja
es funktioniert prinzipiell, ja das ist doch nice
doch easy, guck und jetzt
spackt es auch nicht rum
wenn man das
resized
nicht wie vorher, ist das ordentlich
naja, klar wenn man es
zu klein macht, geht es nicht mehr, aber
ich glaube es hat heute keiner mal 800
mal 600 Monitor
das ist doch mal sehr schick
schon, ok, das sieht schonmal
ganz gut aus, ähm
so, 10, so
und das ist hier, da ist ein bisschen viel Abstand
dazwischen würde ich sagen, ne
ok, wir probieren jetzt nochmal
dass wir, big brain
dass wir noch unter das
Bild, unter das Bild hier
schreiben wir noch den
Shortcut und
den Dateinamen
und in einem der nächsten Streams
machen wir das dann ein bisschen mehr fancy
da machen wir oben irgendwie noch so eine Searchbox
oder sowas hin, wo man dann suchen kann
wenn ich mir vorstelle, man hat da irgendwie
jetzt übertreiben wir mal 150
Bilder drin und man sucht eins, dann ist
das mit einer Searchbox natürlich ein bisschen
ein bisschen einfacher
aber das war heute nicht, weil
ich muss erstmal gucken wie das funktioniert
javascript, lol, ähm
oh, es ist hässlich, ey, ach Gott
es ist so hässlich wie ich das gemacht habe
aber es ist halt
javascript
dafür wäre Bootstrap schick, ja
das stimmt schon, aber, ähm
ich mein, so
einfach, da brauchen wir jetzt nicht komplette Bootstrap reinhauen
für so ein publisches
quit, so
und jetzt muss ich mal überlegen, wie machen wir das jetzt
also ich will
hier unten drunter
den Shortcut und
den Dateinamen stehen haben
die kriege ich schon
Name habe ich hier am Start
übrigens hier
hoffentlich werde ich nicht gebannt
weil ich das Bild hier verknüpft habe
für das Audio Icon
ähm
also das heißt, wir brauchen
da jetzt sowas wie
einen
Diff brauchen wir
ach Gott, wie machen wir das jetzt gescheit
wir brauchen einen Diff
also von der Idee her muss ich jetzt, ja, dass das funktioniert
muss ich jetzt, also jetzt ist es aktuell so
das ist jetzt einfach ein Diff mit 10 Bildern drinnen
so
und wenn ich jetzt unter die Bilder was schreiben will
dann muss das nicht nur das Image Element sein
sondern es muss ein Diff sein
und da drin das Image Element
und zwei Absätze Text
ja, ob das so funktioniert
machen wir das jetzt, ok
ich mache mal irgendwas
was mir gerade so einfällt
also wir brauchen einen Diff
gibt es eigentlich eine schönere Möglichkeit
hier HTML Elemente zu erstellen
als so
ich meine ja, außer irgendein JavaScript Framework
das ist mir schon klar, da könnte man irgendwelche Templates
anlegen oder sowas und wir brauchen irgendwie einen Paragraph
für Text
machen wir das mal so
das wird jetzt, wir machen jetzt
hässliches JavaScript
noch hässlicher, das ist unser Ziel
heute
so, ähm
so, wir appenden das nicht ans
das Image
nicht ans
oberes Element, sondern unser Diff
und da appenden wir dann
das Diff dran
so
und nun müssen wir uns
noch einen Absatz zusammen
basteln, irgendwie
schreiben wir da hin
Shortcut oder sowas
ähm
Shortcut Control
übrigens, wenn ihr irgendwas seht, wie man das schöner machen kann
sagt Bescheid, wie gesagt
JavaScript ist nicht meins
so, ähm
dann sagen wir jetzt hier
Meme sagen wir jetzt, Prefix
Prefix ist unser
na, ich zeig es mal
Prefix ist das, wo die
da Shortcut drinsteht
Prefix
plus
ähm, wie kriege ich denn da jetzt
einen Newline rein, so?
oder geht das anders?
also so, oder wie kriege ich denn da jetzt schön
eine neue Zeile rein?
so, ich mach das mal so, das wird schon
irgendwie funktionieren, so
und auf der nächsten Zeile schreiben wir jetzt rein
Dateiname plus
Name, so
ok, und dann sagen wir
p
so, mal gucken ob das jetzt geht
lol
das ist schon mal nicht schlecht
jetzt kann man sogar einen Shortcut nachgucken
na, wenn ich jetzt nicht mehr weiß
dass mein Shortcut für
was weiß ich
dass mein
Shortcut für Confused
Steuerung W ist, kann ich dann im zweiten Rechner nachgucken
anders drücken
oder ich kann natürlich auch im zweiten Rechner hier klicken
ja, das geht natürlich auch
das ist doch schon mal ganz gut, es sieht jetzt zwar
es sieht nicht schöner aus
aber es sieht auch nicht hässlicher aus, oder?
vielleicht sollten wir noch
eine Schrift einblenden
extra
einen ordentlichen Font
hat der hier ein Font drinnen?
das ist halt nicht
Times New Roman oder sowas
das sieht halt immer kacke aus
Namen braucht man nicht
naja
naja, ich sag mal so, wenn man
wenn man jetzt hier zum Beispiel
ähm, hier zum Beispiel hat man jetzt
einen Text to Speech
und wenn jetzt nicht der Name dabei steht
weiß man ja gar nicht, was das für ein Text to Speech ist
weil Text to Speech hat immer nur das Musik Icon
was zockst du momentan?
also, eigentlich
ich spiel ab und zu mit dem Eax
spielen wir Realm Royale, wobei wir auch schon
eine Weile nicht gespielt haben
ansonsten gerade relativ wenig
ich hoffe ja, dass das neue Battlefield was taugt
wenn es rauskommt
die Beta war jetzt ja so
so halb-halb
ja, ok
der Mason, der blickt durch, der weiß
was Sache ist
das vererbt sich doch alles, ne?
wenn ich das auf das Grid haue, kriegt es alle Elemente darunter auch
kannst du ja, wenn Type Text ist
den Namen ausgeben, ja das stimmt, da hast du recht
das könnte man machen
das ist eine gute Idee
ja ok, die Schrift sieht doch schon viel schöner aus
machen wir noch Font Size
machen wir noch Font Size, reiner und ein bisschen kleiner
ähm
haben wir noch nicht Font Size
Font Size
wie macht man das jetzt eigentlich mittlerweile
JavaScript-technisch schön
das ist ja verpönt, habe ich mir sagen lassen
das ist ja verpönt
mittlerweile, wenn man, dass man
Schriftgrößen Pixel angibt
allerdings weiß ich auch nicht
was die nicht verpönte Variante ist
habe ich mir sagen lassen, letztens von jemand
dass man
Schriftgröße nicht, wenn Pixel angeben soll
in JavaScript
EM, kann sein, ja
EM ist doch die Geschichte
die abhängig ist von DPI vom Bildschirm
und sowas, gell
REM?
was ist REM?
bisschen groß vielleicht
REM?
oder meinst du EM?
EM ist die Einheit, die man als Einheit für Schriftgröße nutzt
ok
Frontend Zeugs
ist immer wieder gut für Überraschungen
das ist jetzt der Unterschied
root EM
das sagt mir jetzt auch relativ wenig
was das sein soll
das ist der Unterschied
die Netzspezialisten, die erklären uns das jetzt
die Einheit REM ist identisch mit der Einheit EM
aber mit einem kleinen extra Dreh
das Element auf den sich die Einheit bezieht
ist das root Element
also das hat im Element, aha, ach das meintest du, ok
ja, was heißt das jetzt?
ach so
ah
also sprich
wenn man quasi was globales
gesetzt hat, dann kann man quasi
abhängig zu dem
seine Schriftgröße ändern
ach so, ah ja
ja das ist, da muss ich Motto69 recht geben
das ist Big Brain
das ist wirklich, das ist schon Expanding Brain
eigentlich, REM zu verwenden
ok, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen klein, jetzt haben wir mal 5
und auch ein busy, haben wir mal 8
übrigens, es ist total behämmert
dass ich jedes mal reload, ich könnte einfach
die HTML Datei
editieren und Browser refreshen
und noch nicht mal das
man könnte sich auch irgendein Browser Plugin installieren
was für ein Refreshed
ja das ist doch schick so
das lassen wir, die Größe
die Größe ist nicht schlecht
so und dann könnten wir noch machen, was eben jemand vorgeschlagen hat
einfach im Browser
die Font Size testen, richtig
ja das hätte man auch machen können
ja eben hat jemand noch gesagt
man könnte ja auch nur die
nur den Name
anzeigen lassen, wenn
der Type
Text ist
das können wir machen
ich zeige euch das mal kurz, ich habe hier nämlich
eingestellt, dass
Moment, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten
warte mal
wie zeige ich euch das jetzt am besten
wir geben mal alles aus hier
warte mal
ich zeige euch das mal kurz
es war ganz schön arg, bis das funktioniert hat
vor allem bis ich das rausgekriegt habe, wie das geht
so
und zwar
haben wir hier nämlich dabei stehen Type
Type Image
und bei
Moment, wo ist es
F11
Moment, wo ist es denn, bin ich jetzt blöd
ah hier
und hier ist Type Text to Speech
Dark Theme für das Memeboard
das schreibe ich mir auf, das brauchen wir
Dark Theme brauchen wir Leute, unbedingt
jetzt ohne Scheiß
ich kann es überhaupt nicht ab, wenn irgendwas
nicht Dark Themed ist
das müssen wir noch machen
Dark Theme, das machen wir
so, ähm
und
so, das heißt wir müssen jetzt gucken, ob
Type Text ist, wie ich das reingekriegt habe
diesen Type, das war gar nicht so einfach
und zwar haben wir hier auf unserem, auf der Serverseite
im Base 16
Tomorrow Night Scheme, ja
das ist übrigens auch mein Konsolen
mein Terminal Theme, beste
ähm, wir haben ja hier diesen I-Namen drin
der Type von, von, ja
von dem Ding, da gibt es hier als Auswahl
Image und Text to Speech
kann man später noch erweitern, vielleicht kann das Ding mal
irgendwann Videos abspielen und sowas
Dark Theme können wir heute auch noch
machen, da muss ich mir auch mal überlegen, wie wir das machen
weil dann brauchen wir irgendeinen Schalter, irgendeinen Button
wo man draufklickt, wo es dann Dark Themed
und da hören dann, da müsst ihr
mir helfen bei, weil da hören dann meine
JavaScript Frontend Ideen
auf, wie man das gescheit machen
kann
gerade mal nachgesehen habe, vor 7 Jahren angefangen
deinem Kanal zu folgen, oh das ist aber schon
das ist ja, quasi ein Jahr nachdem
ich angefangen habe, ungefähr
ne, eineinhalb Jahre
Moin Max, in welcher Sprache
programmierst du? Das ist C-Sharp
und Frontend ist halt leider Gottes
normal JavaScript
also das, das, das
das Web Interface ist halt JavaScript
ähm, genau, so und das
Problem war jetzt, dass der, wenn
er dieses Meme Objekt
nimmt und zum
Client schickt
das macht er hier
Web Interface Send
Update
hier macht er was
hier schickt er die Liste zum Client
und der serialisiert
standardmäßig nur
Enums als Int
also da steht dann nicht im Web
dann kommt nicht beim Client an
irgendwie Meme Type ist Image oder TTS
sondern 0 und 1, das ist natürlich
doof, ne und da
musste man, jetzt wird es echt
abgedreht, da habe ich, da habe ich eine halbe Stunde gesucht
bis ich das gefunden habe, da musste
man hier angeben
dass man, das ist wirklich absolut
Magic, ja, komplett Magic
da musste man hier angeben
Add Chasen
Protocol Options Payload
Serializer Settings Converter
Add String Enum Converter
ich habe das nicht selbst rausgekriegt
muss, muss ich gleich
sagen, ne, das habe ich, das habe ich
aber, the fuck
das ist absolut arcane
Magie, ey, so komplett
arcane Magic hier, dass das dann funktioniert
und so die Sachen keine
Ins mehr sind, sondern die Enum Strings
wunderbar, aber wenn das
funktioniert, das, nice
so, jetzt machen wir erstmal
das mit dem, das hier unten
der Text nur noch da steht, wenn
es Type
für den Theme Switch könnte man CSS Custom
Properties benutzen, könnte man machen
wann cryen das mal wieder
Eax meinst du BDO, ich habe schon
ewig nicht mal BDO gespielt, also ich
log ab und zu ein und hole Reward, aber
richtig gespielt, der Fabian
spielt ja auch gerade nicht, und eigentlich
spiele ich das Game ja auch nur wegen dem Fabian
Move to Payload
so, also, dann machen wir das jetzt mal
wir wollen den Text nur anzeigen
also
wir wollen, och nee, das wird immer ekliger
das JavaScript Zeug, also
sprich, wenn Type
gleich
Text to Speech
wobei, kann man
wie macht man String Interpolation in JavaScript
geht das, geht das, kann man irgendwie sowas
hier machen, sowas hier
und dann gucken
geht, geht das, dass ich
jetzt irgendwie sag, so Meme Type
ähm
geht, geht das irgendwie
warte mal, muss ich mal gucken, da kann man nämlich das
Ip sparen, Backticks
ah, die lassen aber auch kein Zeichen auf der Tastatur
aus, oder, was man verwenden kann
Backticks, das ist neu
das ist neu, das gibt es noch nicht so lange
das habe ich nämlich noch nicht gesehen, bis jetzt
das muss neu sein
also kann ich jetzt hier quasi
sagen, ähm
also nur mal von der Idee her
ich könnte jetzt hier quasi sagen
Meme Type gleich
ähm, ähm, TTS
wenn das TTS ist
dann
ok, das ist auch nicht schöner sonst
ist auch nicht schöner so
dann könnte ich dann quasi sagen, wenn das so ist
dann sagen wir Name
fuck, das funktioniert
ne, guck mal, das funktioniert nicht
ich hab, das stimmt nicht
das geht nicht
oder ist das Highlighting kaputt
achso, ja klar, ich muss ja auch den Ausdruck
fertig machen, äh, Name
gleich
oh, warte, ich blick nochmal durch, äh
Moment, jetzt müsste ich da drinnen, Interpolation
Interpolation, oh, ne, ne, ne, ne
the fuck, was zum Teufel
ne, ne, ne, das machen wir so nicht
geht das so
es sieht, es sieht
kacke aus
gucken, ob das funktioniert
ja
es funktioniert
habt ihr nen, oh, Auskennfuchs
das muss ich mir angucken
das ist nämlich viel besser
äh, zeigt mal, zeigt mal her, ähm
ja, gut, dass du den Kempel
gelöscht hast, da hat er überhaupt nichts versucht
ähm
ach, sowas gibt's
ach
ja, hätte ich das mal gewusst
ach so, ja, das ist doch
viel besser, nice
wusste ich nicht, dass es das gibt
ja, das merchen wir jetzt gleich mal
was, was, was, was ist hier mit dem Projekt
Pfeil kaputt
ja gut, das ist das neue Zeug
das Zeug
ja gut, Standardkarten
ja, das merchen wir jetzt
ähm, ist das was
äh, was, ist zwar etwas
off-topic, aber hast du noch dein Raspberry Pi
ne, hast du noch dein Pi-Hole
aktiv und lohnt es sich, ne lohnt sich nicht
sagt
also für die Leute, die nicht wissen, was das ist
ich zeig das mal kurz, Pi-Hole ist ein DNS
ähm, also
beziehungsweise nein, es ist ein DNS, aber mit Blacklist
also was, das ist eigentlich das
Wichtige, dass es mit Blacklist ist
ähm, das Problem ist
an sich ist die Idee gut
und man muss es auch nicht auf dem Raspberry Pi
installieren, man kann es nicht auch in einer
VM oder so installieren, das muss nicht auf dem Raspberry Pi
laufen, das Problem dabei ist
dass das
anders als jetzt zum Beispiel
ein Werbeblocker im Browser
der das halt quasi aus, der das quasi raus
filtert aus dem HTML
ähm
wenn man DNS
Anfragen blockt
für bekannte
Affiliate-Urls, ne
oder für bekannte Urls, wo es Werbung gibt
dann hängen manche Seiten
also sprich, wenn jetzt irgendeine Seite
Werbung laden will und das funktioniert nicht
dann hängen die
und das ist halt kacke
deswegen verwende ich das Ganze nicht mehr
zum Beispiel die Twitch App
auf dem Smartphone wird mit
Pi-Hole unbenutzbar
weil das Ding ist irgendwie
darauf angewiesen sich zu connecten
zu seinem Werbe-Netzwerk
und wenn es das nicht kann
hängt es einfach bei jedem Klick 30 Sekunden
bis es ein Timeout gibt
und das ist halt kacke
deswegen verwende ich das nicht mehr
es ist unbenutzbar, so aber wir merchen jetzt
den Krams vom
VOSCAN Fox, das ist ganz toll
ich mach das grad mal zu
kann man
kann man im Visual Studio irgendwas
was aktualisieren, was pullen oder so
geht das?
egal
wir merchen das jetzt
ich bin eingeloggt, ich darf das machen
ich will das nicht reviewen, ich will merchen
wie mercht man überhaupt in GitHub?
Moment
also ich meine, ich kann über die Konsole merchen
klar, aber kann man nicht auch über das Web-Interface merchen?
ach hier!
Merch Pull Request, easy, steht auch sogar da
aber einfach kilometerlange
Hosted hat die alles blockt, das kann man natürlich auch machen
so
was ist eigentlich das hier?
VOSCAN Fox, was hat er denn hier
umgestellt?
Package Config Designer
das sind irgendwelche
Visual Studio Settings von dir wahrscheinlich
aber das passt, das nehmen wir so
das ist eine gute Idee
wir merchen das jetzt mal
ok
bam
ok, wir haben es gemercht
dann pullen wir mal
jetzt die Preisfrage
wie pullt man in Visual Studio?
ich hab ehrlich gesagt
nicht den Schimmer einer Ahnung
deswegen machen wir das jetzt nicht über Visual Studio
sondern über die Shell
da weiß ich wenigstens wie es funktioniert
mal den ganzen Tag nichts anderes
sonst
ekliges Windows Terminal, dreck ein Drop
geht übrigens
Hey Cortana Pull
oh das probieren wir jetzt mal aus
wie macht man Cortana an?
oh ich bin so ein Windows Noob
ich hab echt keine Ahnung
das machen wir jetzt
wir sagen Cortana jetzt
dass sie git pull machen soll
wie macht man Cortana an?
ähm
äh
ich hab das noch nie verwendet
Cortana
ähm
wie geht das?
ey
Windows, ohne Scheiß Leute
es war Real Talk
ich sag jetzt mal so wie ich das empfinde
Windows ist
was das finden von Einstellungen anbelangt
der allerletzte
Bodensatz, das ist so beschissen
es ist wirklich
richtig beschissen
und es ist ja Windows 10 und ich finde Windows 10 an sich nicht schlecht
von allen Sachen ist es noch das kleinste Problem
ähm
jetzt wo es noch 3, 4
Menüs gibt, wo was ist, alte Menüs,
neue, noch neuere
es ist abgrundtief scheiße ey
Windows Settings zu finden
was rechtsklickt auf Taskleiste
und dann
Cortana
Cortana, Cortana, Cortana
wie mach ich Cortana an?
Search
ich mein, warum
warum kann man nicht einfach sagen
Cortana und das starten
und dann, dann geht's auf
warum ist das so?
so, ich will jetzt wissen wie das geht
ach fick dich, kein Bock Cortana
wir pullen jetzt so
übrigens
eine Sache, die ich auch immer auf der Arbeit erzähle
viele Leute haben sich angewöhnt
anstatt Git Pull zu machen
anstatt die
die volle
vollqualifizierte
Schreibweise
und das Problem dabei ist
dass vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit
Git die Default Settings waren
bei Push
bei Pull bin ich, bin ich ganz sicher, wahrscheinlich bei Pull auch
zumindest bei Push
alle Branches die man lokal hatte
zu pushen
und das will man meistens nicht
meistens will man nur den Branch pushen auf dem man drauf ist
ich glaube mittlerweile hat sich das Default geändert
also sprich, dass Git Push
nur noch den Branch macht auf dem man gerade drauf ist
standardmäßig
aber es war vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
war das Default Settings
die wollte man gar nicht pushen
deswegen habe ich mir angewöhnt
ich schreibe immer die komplette Schreibweise hin
oh man
ok, ich mache mal Wichelsudie zu
ich glaube das hat Probleme damit, wenn am Hintergrund was läuft
ok
gucken wir mal, was hat er denn für Schmerzen
achso, ja gut
kann ich machen
warum sagt er mir nicht einfach hier
mal bitte Konflikt
achso, weil ich noch nicht committet habe
ähm
ich will die Änderung eigentlich auch gar nicht
na wenn ich einen Git Stash mache
muss ich einen Git Stash Pop danach machen
dann habe ich auf jeden Fall irgendeinen Konflikt
wie könnte ich das jetzt wirklich clever machen
ich will das nicht committen
ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich da einen Konflikt kriege
kann schon sein
wenn sich das jetzt parallel geändert hat
ich meine wir können das mal machen
das könnte ich auch machen, ich könnte die Datei auch wieder resetten
jaja
das schöne an Git ist, und man sieht es hier auch gerade im Chat
es gibt 20.000 Varianten
wie man irgendwas machen kann
wenn man das jetzt vergessen hat, sehr schön
Pop, war das 1 oder einfach nur
ich glaube einfach nur Pop
dann macht er das letzte
siehste, von wegen ich habe keinen Konflikt
aber das ist nicht schlimm, da wird wahrscheinlich
ziemlich überschaubar sein
oh ne, wir sind hier unter Windows
äh
habe ich den Wim drauf
please, ok gut
ok da spackt ihr irgendwie rum
ich resette das jetzt einfach
Wim Woodface
so und jetzt haben wir hier zumindest keine
wat?
also
kannst du das irgendwie so machen, ne
wie mache ich das jetzt am besten, lass mal kurz
kurz äh
man könnte den Krempel jetzt natürlich
ich will eigentlich die Version
nehmen, ich weiß
irgendwas machen
kannst du das jetzt abbrechen
wat
was hat er denn für Schmerzen
ja ich weiß
ich könnte doch einfach sagen
warum geht denn das nicht
warum kann ich den Scheiß nicht zurücksetzen
auf
hm
so ich weiß, jetzt habe ich den Konflikt noch drin
also das müsst ihr mir nicht
ich weiß, dass das nicht so gedacht ist
ist aber doof
was ist gefuddelt da
was ich jetzt überhaupt nicht checke ist
dass es angeblich ein Merch gibt
aber dann doch nicht, there is no Merch
the fuck, warum nicht
ok jetzt machen wir ein Checkout
ok
beste
wat
warum ist der Scheiß jetzt noch drinne
bin ich, jetzt bin ich grad verwirrt
habe ich das Ding schon
committed oder was
was hat das Ding für Schmerzen, warum geht das nicht
oder wie ist da überhaupt die richtige
Schreibweise, Checkout von
hä das so
ah
aha
jetzt haben wir natürlich nicht die letzte
ok guck mal, guck mal ob der Krempel jetzt einfach
funktioniert
ähm, wenn ich resette ich den Kram noch mal
gut ist
ich glaube ich habe mehr Zeit damit verbracht
getrennt, was zu fix wie zu programmieren
wobei es geht, es geht eigentlich
also wenn man den meisten
Leuten für die wichtigen Branchen das Push
Berechnungen wegnimmt, dann ist es kein Problem
es ist immer noch ein Problem, wenn alle dürfen
und alle rumwursten
ok, anscheinend
war das jetzt ok und geht jetzt
was auch immer
so und jetzt muss ich mal gucken
ob das geht, jetzt habe ich das vom letzten Comet
und jetzt ist es
von diesem Comet
ob das vom Auskennfuchs ist
das ist vom Auskennfuchs
ok, nice
gut
dann passt alles, dann haben wir jetzt das Richtige
ok, weiter geht's
ähm, Max
hast du dir
doch die erste Staffel von der Serie
You are Wanted angesehen
mit dem Schweighöfer, hast du dich auch in die zweite
schon gewagt oder auch gleich, nein habe ich nicht geguckt?
ich habe auch die erste nicht ganz geguckt
das war mir zu doof, ehrlich gesagt
ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hat das
ja eine super Auflösung gehabt, aber das war für mich so eine
irgendwie so eine
so eine gewollt
und nicht gekonnt Geschichte
ich bin jetzt ja auch niemand, der unbedingt
jetzt deutsche Sachen
also deutsche Produktionen schlecht reden
muss, so nach dem Motto
es ist alles scheiße
wir haben ja auch kreative Leute und
waren auch ganz gute Sachen, aber diese Serie hat mir nicht gefallen
und ich wollte
ich wusste bis jetzt gar nicht, dass es überhaupt eine zweite Staffel
dazu gibt, da muss ich dem Sbarro
Recht geben, ich wusste nicht, dass eine zweite
Staffel dafür existiert
so, ok, da gucken wir uns mal an, was der Auskennfuchs
hier gemacht hat
außer sich auskennen natürlich
gucken wir mal, ob das
funktioniert, ansonsten müssen wir das mal
resetten
bevor wir mal nachgucken, wo hat er das gemacht, hier
Embedded File Provider in Web Interface
Web Interface
Embedded
File Provider, ok
und das funktioniert jetzt
da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob
das funktioniert
jetzt, der Moment der Wahrheit
nein, funktioniert nicht
Auskennfuchs, es ist kaputt
es ist kaputt
es funktioniert nicht
was hat er denn für, ja
Favicon, ok
aber warum ist es kaputt?
warum ist es kaputt?
warum geht das jetzt nicht mehr?
ich meine im Prinzip
hat sich ja nichts geändert, außer das
die Indexdatei geht doch
hä?
kann das sein, dass einfach keine Memes drinnen sind?
dass das gerade rumbuckt?
da sind keine Memes drinnen
keine Panik, Auskennfuchs
du hast nichts kaputt gemacht
da sind keine Memes mehr drinnen
logischerweise, weil ich mein Projekt
File überschrieben habe, wo ich die hier
reingocopy und pastet habe
kein Wunder, dass das nicht geht, alles gut
das liegt nicht an dir
ah, wat
die exist, piss dich
stimmt überhaupt nicht
Fake News, das existet überhaupt nicht
kann man dem Ding nicht sagen
refresh Ordner mal?
warum geht das nicht, warum kann ich dem Ding nicht sagen
refresh mir mal den Ordner
warum geht das nicht?
kann doch nicht sein
naja
F5
nein
F5 bringt hier glaube ich nichts drinnen
F5 ist Build
Visual Studio ist Crap
nein, ich mag Visual Studio
Visual Studio ist gut
mir gefällt Visual Studio
kann man das jetzt einfach wieder neu reinziehen
oder spackt es dann rum?
wahrscheinlich spackt es rum, wenn ich es jetzt neu reinziehe
ok, wir machen das jetzt anders
ich kopiere den Scheiß jetzt da hin
so
dann löschen wir den Inhalt
dass es jetzt wieder passt
so, und jetzt
droppen wir den Inhalt wieder rein
Visual Studio kann das sonst nicht anders
F5 für Builds
ja, mein Lieblings
das habe ich jetzt hier aber noch gar nicht eingestellt
mein Lieblings Shortcut für Run ist
STRG R
gefällt mir am besten, STRG R
kommt man schnell hin
und passt irgendwie zu halt Run
ok, geht, geht wieder
alles gut
ok, gucken wir mal ob es funktioniert
Bam
Nice
Nice, das brauche ich mal ein komisches Extract
und rumkopiere nicht mehr
so ist es viel besser
viel viel schöner
viel viel schöner ist das so
ich wusste gar nicht, dass es sowas gibt
das ist eine super Geschichte, muss ich sagen
gefällt mir
da kann man das Ding direkt aus den Embedded Resources
kann man da HTML Zeug füttern
das ist richtig, sehr sehr nice
so als hätten andere Leute schon die Probleme haben
kann man dann auch das Icon abrufen?
welches Icon?
das Problem war
dass er das nicht in Output kopiert hat
obwohl es im Ordner drin war
und weil es halt nicht im Output war
also weil er das nicht kannte die Datei
konnte er es halt auch nicht in Output kopieren
was ich halt nicht verstehe ist
warum er mir nicht sagen kann, ok
wenn in diesem Ordner was drin liegt
refresh mal, dass ich hier wieder Settings drin habe
aber was auch immer, Visual Studio
die wissen schon wie das geht
ok, weiter geht's
wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
oder habe ich irgendwas überlesen überhaupt?
Zeit mal her... genau
ich habe jetzt mal den zweiten Stapel
oder wie fandest du es denn?
äh, No Happy Meal for you
du hast ja gefragt
wie fandest du es denn?
ich mein nur weil ich das scheiße fand
heißt es ja nicht, dass auch alle scheiße finden
weiß ich ja nie
so
weiter geht's
wir waren ja ursprünglich dabei
wo sind wir denn eigentlich gerade stehen geblieben
bevor ich den Krempel gemerged habe?
genau, wir haben unser JavaScript noch hässlicher gemacht
ich mein guckt euch das mal an, das ist doch echt nicht
mal feierlich hier, was ist das denn?
Mr. Robot gesehen?
ja die erste Staffel
was war deine Lieblingsserie des letzten Jahres?
hm, ich habe nicht so viele
geguckt, ich habe ein paar auf Amazon geguckt
lass mir überlegen, was ist denn so
was ist mir besonders
im Kopf hängen geblieben, ich muss mal kurz gucken
also das letzte was ich geguckt habe war
Preacher Staffel 2
ich logg mich hier gerade mal bei Amazon ein
im zweiten Monitor
kann ich nämlich mal gucken
ähm, Preacher Staffel 2?
habe ich geguckt
fand ich jetzt
die ersten Folgen richtig gut
da hat es auch richtig Zug drauf
und war spannend
aber dann so die zweite Hälfte hat nachgelassen
Mr. Robot hat auch finde ich nachgelassen
in der zweiten Hälfte von der ersten Staffel
deswegen habe ich mir die anderen Staffeln
gar nicht mehr angeguckt
Serien, was habe ich denn geguckt?
The Night Manager habe ich geguckt
genau das fand ich gut, das fand ich richtig gut
obwohl es überhaupt keine Action großartig hatte
äh
aber ich mag die Schauspieler
und ähm
ich fand es auch sehr spannend gemacht
also das war nice
das hat mir gefallen
das war auch, ich würde sagen das war so mit das beste
was ich dieses Jahr geguckt habe
das hier, ich zeige es mal kurz
was da
mit Dr. House und Loki
ich weiß leider nicht wie die Typen heißen
Amazon
was da
er fand ich nice
das war eines der wenigen Serien
die glücklicherweise komplett abgeschlossen waren
also von Anfang bis Ende
das Ende war vorbei
da war Schluss
also sprich wenn die eine zweite Staffel machen
können sie was komplett neues machen
oder es einfach auch sein lassen
weil das ist wirklich mal eine Serie
die braucht gar keine zweite Staffel
einfach vorbei
was habe ich noch geguckt
American Gods habe ich noch geguckt
war genauso
Hälfte geil, zweite Hälfte langweilig
langweiliger
das einzige geile bei American Gods war
die letzte Folge
die letzten 10 Minuten der letzten Folge
wo Odin am Start war
das war auch nice
ähm
was habe ich noch geguckt
Badlands habe ich geguckt, übelster Trash
ich würde nicht sagen übelster Crap
aber
übelster Trash
ähm, wer fällt mir jetzt nicht ein
keine Ahnung
das ist eine Serie die ihr geguckt habt
wo wir gerade dabei sind
ok wir müssen jetzt mal kurz weitermachen
also ähm, wo sind wir eigentlich stehen geblieben
ich bin jetzt voll verwirrt
ähm, Templates EM
ähm
Dönerpizza extra nice
Dönerpizza sehr sehr nice
ich hatte mal einen Dönerburger
das gibt man
bei einem Lieferservice in Frankfurt
gab es mal stand bei denen
wenn du online bestellt hast
stand da Dönerburger
also
das war gar nichts
also das
gucken ob es das noch gibt
Taxi Baba Burger
ne ne ne
egal es hatte halt mit Döner überhaupt nichts zu tun
es war
quasi irgendwie so
es war noch nicht mal Dönerfleisch
es war ein Burger
es war aber der Rest war quasi
Döner also es waren irgendwie so
dieses Grauzeugs drauf
und dieses Brot und sowas
und das war im Prinzip ein Brot mit zwei Frikadellen hintendran
und das hat überhaupt nicht geschmeckt
wenn ich türkische Frikadellen futtern will
dann hol ich mir ein Köftesandwich oder sowas
das schmeckt dann auch geil
aber Dönerburger hat überhaupt nicht geschmeckt
das war so eines der schlechtesten Sachen
die ich je mal im Lieferdienst bestellt hab
ok ähm
ja Preacher
fand ich nicht schlecht die zweite Staffel
der hat nachgelassen in der zweiten Hälfte
ich hab letztens die Nachricht von Amazon gekriegt, dass es jetzt am 2. Mai ist
und es auch irgendwie die dritte Staffel oder so schon gibt
muss ich mal gucken
ok ich muss mal kurz konzentrieren
also wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben
wir wollten ein komisches Crit machen, Crit haben wir gemacht
wo haben wir denn jetzt aufgehört, was wollten wir denn machen Leute
helft mir mal auf die Sprünge
was wollten wir denn machen
äh ah ja ähm
nen Dark Theme wollten wir noch machen
aber vorher wollten wir noch irgendwas anderes machen
äh
also das letzte was ich gemacht hab ist hier unten die
die Sachen ein und aus zu blenden
ich mein das ist doch jetzt ganz
nice
oh make a little
ich bin immer noch begeistert
wieder automatisch refreshed
dass das vorbei ist
ähm
was wollten wir denn jetzt machen
ich bin voll verwirrt gerade
jetzt hab ich voll abgelenkt
ich weiß nicht was ich machen wollte
POG, ne POG hab ich, leider hab ich alle
bei der Twitch TV Emotes schon aufgebraucht
mehr geht nicht
vielleicht sollte man das umbenennen von
blub txt in omega lul
den Bitcoin Miner
ja nein das zeige ich euch natürlich nicht
on stream oder das ist doch eher bescheu
ähm
den bau ich ein wenn ihr nicht mehr zuguckt
den Bitcoin Miner
inklusive Keylogger und Remote Zugriff
Ethereum Miner
Monero Miner
Ripple Miner
alles Miner
so wie Cristiano Ronaldo
der hatte ja auf seiner Webseite auch
Ethereum hat er gemeint
kannst du dem Diff mal nen BG Color geben
ja könnte ich mal
achso Darksteam wollten wir machen
so Leute
nachdem ich davon wirklich keine Ahnung hab
wie man sowas Javascript mäßig
möglichst simpel macht
brauch ich da mal eure Hilfe
das heißt wir müssen das jetzt zusammen machen
irgendwie bewältigen
und zwar
wir machen nen Button
Code Pen
ok ich mach das mal auf
Dark Light Switch
ok copy paste
copy paste
copy pasta
so
gucken wir mal ob das funktioniert
just press the button above to toggle
Poggers
so brauche ich das
so muss das sein so will ich das haben Darksteam
das brauchen wir
wir brauchen unbedingt nen Darksteam
das geht nicht ohne
guckt mal überlegt euch mal ne
ihr spielt was und dann müsst ihr auf einmal
also ne überlegt euch mal
ihr habt hier jetzt sowas auf
so ihr spielt jetzt hier irgendwie
bam in your face
und dann guckt ihr auf dem zweiten Monitor
also das geht nicht
deswegen braucht es ein Darksteam
ok
wir wo hast denn das her
wir hatten das gepostet
ist das von Stack Overflow
oder hast du das gerade gebastelt
ok das heißt wir brauchen erstmal nen Button
aha Body ID
Body ID Body
but why
achso dass man das austauschen kann
war von Stack Overflow
ok wie funktioniert denn der Kram
jetzt mal lass mal in Ruhe angucken
ok das ist ein Button mit
nem On Click
zu dem hier
selber basteln
ja das ist richtig
hahaha
ok
was diese Funktion macht
ist ja im Prinzip nix anderes wie
das Body Element
schnappen
gucken wie die aktuelle
CSS Klasse ist
und dann
schauen
wenn Current Class Dark Mode ist
dann zu Light Mode switchen
und wenn es eben nicht so ist
dann zu Dark Mode switchen
ok das ist simpel das check ich ja
mal rein
kann man eigentlich so globale
kann man so Sachen hier oben irgendwie drin definieren
ok das heißt mal ein Body
der braucht auch ein Body das ich den finde
aha so
und da haben wir jetzt hier den Button
Class Dark Mode
Stack Overflow Driven Programming
Dark Mode
Button
so
Button da war jetzt irgendwie ein Button
ich will einfach nur testen ob es wirklich ist
Button da oben hin
On Click das da
hoffentlich findet er das jetzt
und dann muss man noch die CSS Geschichten kopieren
Dark Color Light Color
achso ah man kann
seit wann kann man den CSS Variablen machen
das ist seit CSS 3
achso
ne das ist
ahja ok besser
ähm
ok jetzt müssen wir mal überlegen was braucht man davon
was braucht man eigentlich
wir wollen ja einfach nur mal kurz gucken ob es geht
Body Dark Mode Body Body äh
Body Dark Mode
Body Light Mode
das sind eigentlich die zwei die wir gerade brauchen
Body Dark Mode
Body Light Mode
so ich will einfach mal gucken was jetzt passiert wenn man da drauf klickt
Bam
Dark Mode
schreckt
eats as fuck alter
ok die Rahmen sehen jetzt nicht so ganz richtig aus
aber da können wir noch was machen
eats as fuck
hehehe
krasse Effekte mal hier
zur Geltung bringen
ok ähm
also die Seite ist nicht wirklich schön
also doch oder
doch die Seite ist schon ein bisschen schöner geworden
doch muss man sagen ne
bisschen schöner ist die schon
und außerdem macht Dark Theme alles besser
ok ähm
was passiert hier gerade
wir basteln
wir schaffen gerade das Frontend
für ähm
mein Streamer Meme Tool etwas
hübscher ohne das ich mich großartig
mit CSS und Javascript auskenne
und das ist äh schwierig
warum labert da einer
das ist die Epic Chillstep
Collection da darf keiner labern
wo
ich will nicht printen
Chill Your Mind Radio
ne das singt auch einer das ist doof
passt auf Leute
de de de de de de de
so
genug
Ori soundtrack beste
ups wat
so es ist ganz gut
magst mich nicht auf
Twitter entblocken
äh
kommt drauf an
weshalb ich dich geblockt habe
falls du sich da falls ich da ein wenig
ähm
überreagiert haben sollte entblock ich dich gerne
aber ich muss mir erstmal angucken weshalb ansonsten
Bäm
Wie ist dein Twitter-Account?
Bestimmt schon ein paar Jahre
Ja, post einfach mal einen Twitter-Account
Ich entblocke dich dann
CortanaFlip
Okay, keine Ahnung
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich dich geblockt habe
Ich weiß, ich habe dich entblockt
Oh, ich weiß, warum ich dich geblockt habe
Soll ich es zeigen?
Ist nichts Schlimmes
Echt nichts Schlimmes
Also, du hast es nicht verdient, dafür geblockt zu werden
Aber ich war da gerade ein wenig angepisst, glaube ich
Aber ich zeige dir, warum ich dich geblockt habe
Das ist überhaupt nichts Schlimmes
Ich sage es gleich dazu
Ich hätte dich dafür echt nicht blocken müssen
Das haben wir gerade echt scheiße gespielt
Also, wie immer
Also, ihr könnt euch vorstellen
Ich war ein wenig angepisst, dass wir verloren haben
Dementsprechend war ich so sauer
Dass ich wahrscheinlich jeden gebannt habe
Der irgendwas Dummes drauf geschrieben hat
Nee, das hast du nicht
Das hast du nicht verdient, dafür geblockt zu werden
Ich vermute mal, dass wir da gerade irgendeinen ESL
Also, Overwatch ESL oder so gespielt haben
Gerade
Zu dem Zeitpunkt
Ja, ja gut, wenn Cyrus da drauf geantwortet hat
Da haben wir gerade
Da haben wir wahrscheinlich gerade Weekly Cup gespielt
Und auf die Fresse gekriegt
Und ich war sauer
Und da habe ich dich gebannt, weil du dummes Zeug drauf geschrieben hast
Nein, den Bann hast du nicht verdient
Also, der ist jetzt wieder weg
Warum hast du mich noch gebannt?
War klar, das war keine gute Idee
Das heißt, du hast den 1.1 von dir
Wenn du dann hier mit den 2 Auto rausgeholt hast
Wird dann so was auf Englisch laufen
Die simple Begründung dafür ist
Dass, wenn irgendetwas nicht funktioniert
Ich besser suchen kann
Such mal nach deutschen Fehlermeldung
Und such mal nach englischen Fehlermeldung
Wo findest du schneller was?
Willst du noch so was wie LightDB einbauen
Damit man die Memes in die DB hochladen kann
Anstatt einbauen
Ja, da habe ich mir schon Gedanken drüber gemacht
Über LightDB oder sqlite
Und zwar habe ich mir das so überlegt, das ist jetzt halt relativ primitiv.
Das nimmt einen Ordner und Static File und haut das Ganze raus.
Ich werde den Memes noch, warte mal, wo ist das denn hier, werde ich noch Unique IDs verpassen.
Also hier, wenn es hier angelegt wird, kriegen die noch eine Unique ID, die man dann auch im Frontend verwenden kann.
Und dann mache ich auch im Webinterface, also hier kann man jetzt ja aktuell nichts uploaden.
Der haut seine Static Files raus, hier unter Slash Image und gut ist.
Ich werde dann, wenn alle Memes eine ID haben, werde ich dann quasi noch ein paar Routen registrieren oder irgendeinen Controller noch reinhauen,
der quasi das Get annimmt mit der ID, beziehungsweise auch einen Post mit einem neuen Meme drinnen.
Und dann kann man auch über das Webinterface neue Sachen hochladen, die ihr dann im Hintergrund in den Ordner kopiert.
Ja, ja, das habe ich mir schon überlegt, sowas in der Richtung.
Wobei man dazu nicht unbedingt eine DB bräuchte.
Ich meine, da kann es immer noch in den Ordner kopieren im Hintergrund.
Da kann zwar jeder dann was hin kopieren auf den Rechner, aber ich meine, das läuft im lokalen Netzwerk.
Wir könnten das ja auch noch passwortschützen oder so.
So, okay, weiter im Text.
Bisschen leise, oder?
Ich glaube, der Ori-Soundtrack ist einfach gerade leise.
Okay, Dark Steam haben wir jetzt auch.
Das Einzige, was noch richtig hässlich aussieht, sind die Kästchen da drumherum.
Das machen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen anders.
Generell, warum mache ich hier eigentlich...
Warum genau? Was habe ich mir eigentlich dabei gedacht?
Was habe ich mir eigentlich dabei gedacht? Warum habe ich das mit Inline-Styles gemacht?
Ja, das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt, Sebarro.
An alle, die es jetzt geschrieben haben, dass man die Bilder nicht lokal braucht.
Dass man halt auch Urls irgendwie anzeigen kann.
Dass man im Hintergrund runterlegt und dann anzeigt und sowas.
Allerdings, das müsst ihr halt selbst dann eintragen.
Dann bin ich da fein raus, was Urheberrecht angeht.
Ich mache das dann irgendwie so, dass man sagen kann, hier diese Url...
Also wir erweitern ja das Webfront dann noch ein bisschen.
Dass man da sagen kann, diese Url will ich...
Dann, keine Ahnung, auf Control-D oder so.
Und dann zeigt er das an.
Der PC aus Kaufberatung 2014, ja nice.
Da haben wir uns auch viel Gedanken damals gemacht.
Keiniges dabei gedacht.
Okay, dann machen wir das jetzt mal...
Wie macht man das jetzt ordentlich CSS?
Also...
Wir gucken erstmal...
Also wir wollen auf jeden Fall nicht...
Also wir wollen jetzt erstmal...
Sag mal...
Warum macht man jetzt eigentlich...
Warte mal, so stylt das komplette Body-Element mit der Class-Dark-Mode, ne?
Das heißt das doch in CSS.
Also sprich, das betrifft das Body-Element und dann ist es nur für Class-Dark-Mode.
Also das heißt doch eigentlich, könnten wir doch sowas machen wie...
Image.
Und dann machen wir sowas wie Image-TTS.
Dann wird es Purple.
Kann man...
Okay, Leute.
Jetzt...
Jetzt jetzt jetzt mal Advanced.
Ich probiere jetzt mal was.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das funktioniert.
Also man könnte doch sagen, man macht so eine Base-Klasse CSS-mäßig.
Das ist dann sowas hier.
Oh, guck mal, der formatiert das auch.
Also quasi sowas hier.
Base-Image.
Und dann sagt man quasi als nächstes...
Advanced.
Ja, für mich als JavaScript-Loop ist das Advanced.
So, und dann sage ich Image.Text-to-Speech.
Also mit Text-to-Speech klar.
Ist klar.
Und ähm...
Boah, brauchst du auch noch was anderes?
Ah, Active.
Active.
Ähm.
Geht das so?
Most immersive CSS ever.
Ja, so ist es.
So ist es.
Warum rückt der das ja jetzt so scheiße ein?
Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen Windows, PowerShell und Eingabe-Ausforderung?
Äh, Eingabe-Ausforderung.
Eingabe-Aufforderung.
Ähm.
Die ist neuer.
Ja.
PowerShell kann .NET-Zeugs aufrufen und ist viel moderner als Batch.
Das einzige Problem, was Windows hat, ist, dass es keine gescheite Terminal-Anwendung gibt.
Also, Windows-Leute verwechseln ja immer das hier mit dem Terminal.
Beziehungsweise das hier mit dem Terminal.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Für jemand, der es halt nicht anders kennt, ist das das Gleiche.
Quasi der Inhalt und das Fenster ist das Gleiche.
Das stimmt aber nicht.
Das Fenster, die Anwendung drum, ist quasi der Terminal.
Beziehungsweise der Terminal-Emulator.
Und das da drin ist die Shell, die da drinnen läuft.
Leider gibt es kein gescheites Terminal unter Windows, standardmäßig.
Deswegen verwende ich immer CMDR, wo das Gleiche drin läuft, wie in diesem Windows-Terminal.
Also die gleiche Shell.
Ähm, aber halt mit, äh, viel besseren Sachen.
Ja.
Viel, viel nicer.
Git vorinstalliert und, äh, Suche, Reverse-Suche nach Kommandos.
So.
Okay, ähm.
Moment, Leute, das war ja eben quasi kein richtiges CSS, was wir auf der Seite gesehen haben,
sondern so eine CSS-Template-Sprache, ne?
Ähm, also was wie Sass quasi.
Wie macht man denn jetzt Variablen in CSS3?
Also kann ich irgendwie in CSS sagen, dass das Dark ist...
Geht das irgendwie?
Ich sag Dark ist...
Dark ist, ähm, so?
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht gehen, aber wie macht man das in CSS?
Und dann sag ich hier unten irgendwie sowas wie Dark.
Dark.
Minus, minus Name-Wert.
Also genauso, wie es da steht eigentlich.
Also, okay, ich probiere das jetzt mal.
Also quasi so.
Dann sagen wir jetzt hier...
Ups.
Jetzt mal rückgängig machen, den Kram.
Dark.
Also sag ich jetzt sowas wie...
Light.
MaxLand CSS live on stream.
So.
Und dann...
Ups.
Jetzt habe ich falsche kopiert.
Ziemlich neu.
Ja, ja, ich sehe es, ich sehe es.
Was quasi war...
Man sieht es...
Ach, guck mal, guck mal!
Wo ist jetzt...
Die haben sogar Autocomplete dafür.
Ja?
Charakter.
Ich habe es auch gerade gemerkt.
Nice.
Das ist cool.
Das gefällt mir.
So, das heißt, wenn wir das jetzt starten...
Geht nicht.
Ist kaputt.
Warum ist es kaputt?
Wir haben es kaputt gemacht.
Ups.
Oh, jetzt habe ich es wieder beendet.
Haben es kaputt gemacht.
Was haben wir denn jetzt kaputt gemacht?
Ich meine, es geht eindeutig davor kaputt,
weil unsere JavaScript-Funktion nicht mehr defined ist.
Hm.
Ich habe es kaputt gemacht.
Ich weiß...
Ich weiß aber nicht, durch was.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich mache das mal wieder rückgängig kurz.
Ich weiß nicht, durch genau was ich kaputt gemacht habe,
aber ich habe es kaputt gemacht.
Okay, mal gucken, ob es jetzt wieder funktioniert.
Was?
Was habe ich denn jetzt hier kaputt gemacht?
Warum geht mir das jetzt nicht mehr?
Klammer fehlt?
Nee.
Was, die Klammer fehlt?
Die Klammer fehlt!
Warum ist die Klammer denn weg?
WTF?
Warum ist die Klammer weg?
Wo ist sie hin?
Okay, geht mir doch.
Okay, da können wir jetzt gerade...
Können wir das jetzt nochmal machen.
Geil.
Toll.
Da war das gar nicht so schlecht.
Okay, aber ich probiere das jetzt mal mit dem Image aus,
was ich vorhatte.
Das mit den Variablen.
Also das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier quasi sagen,
Image.
So, Image.
So, das Standard-Image kriegt diesen Style.
Genau, da kann ich das hier nämlich schon mal wegnehmen.
Das müsste immer noch funktionieren.
Ne?
Du kannst der Browser-Konsole vertrauen.
Nee.
Kann ich nicht.
Weil, es könnte doch sein,
nachdem mein Script direkt hier drunter ist,
und wenn ich hier irgendwas kaputt gemacht habe,
was dann taktisch nicht richtig ist,
dass das hier dann jetzt gar nicht ausgeführt wird.
Nachdem ich das hier alles inline habe
und nicht einzeln auf mehrere Files verteilt,
was ich jetzt übrigens aber
dank dem Pull-Request von Auskenntfuchsproblemen habe,
und das machen könnte.
Ich könnte das jetzt alles aufteilen in HTML und CSS-Files
und JavaScript-Files,
weil wir können jetzt ja einfach alle Ressourcen raushauen,
ohne dass wir da irgendwie Entpack-Action machen müssen.
It's live ist das.
So, und dann machen wir jetzt noch ein Image.
Image.
TTS.
Das kriegt eigentlich zusätzlich Plus
als, ähm,
als Bonds,
Border-Color kriegt das,
kriegt das Purple.
Border-Color kriegt das Purple.
So, und dann haben wir noch Active.
Active
is green.
So, und dann passt das, glaube ich.
Warum musst du immer starten stoppen,
wenn du etwas bearbeitest?
Sind doch nur HTML, CSS, nein, doch.
Ähm, also ich
hab das hier embedded drin
und das ist nicht so optimal, ja.
Ich will halt, dass ich eine Anwendung ausliefern kann,
wo alles drin ist.
Deswegen, deswegen ist das hier alles eingebaut
und das surft das halt immer nur
aus seinen Ressourcen.
Das ist aber doof,
das müsste ich ein bisschen schöner machen.
Ich könnte ja einfach checken,
ob ich quasi im Debug-Mode bin.
Dann surft er die aus einem,
aus einem Directory,
in dem ich editieren kann.
Und, ja, ja, das machen wir, glaube ich, auch mal.
Ja, das ist doch viel besser.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich, ich gucke, ob ich im Debug-Mode bin.
Das hätte ich gleich machen sollen.
Äh, das ist eine gute Idee.
Äh, ich gucke, ob ich im Debug-Mode bin.
Wenn ich im Debug-Mode bin, dann surfen wir einfach hier
in den Directory
und
wenn ich im,
ja, nicht im Debug-Mode bin,
dann surfen wir quasi das,
also dann, ja, geben wir am Browser raus,
die, das Embedded.
Ja, das ist eigentlich viel besser.
Das können wir, das können wir klar machen.
Einmal kurz gucken, ob mein, mein, äh, CSS-Gedöns
funktioniert, was ich jetzt gebastelt hab.
Also, sprich, anstatt hier unten
irgendwelche Inline-Styles zu setzen,
könnte ich jetzt ja auch
einfach sagen,
ähm, wie sag ich das eigentlich?
Class, ne? Class.
Class.
Class-List.
Add.
Und dann sag ich, ähm,
Active.
Das heißt, ich hau jetzt hier eine
CSS-Class dran.
Active.
So, und hier unten hau ich eine
CSS-Class dran,
die sagt Text-to-Speech.
Boah, ob das klappt?
Bin da mal gespannt.
Funktioniert?
Es funktioniert?
Nice.
So, dann können wir jetzt noch die,
warte mal, ich wollte, wir machen das mit dem
Web-Interface, ähm,
wie kann ich eigentlich checken?
Äh, check if debug.
Na, so will ich das nicht machen.
Kann man nicht irgendwie abfragen?
If debug? Geht das nicht irgendwie?
Was läuft denn hier?
Das Meme-Tool läuft hier.
Beziehungsweise Feinschliff.
Ah ja, System-Digga, Debugger ist attached.
Das brauch ich, genau.
Und im Hintergrund läuft das Soundtrack von Ori.
So, also das heißt, von der Idee her könnte man doch jetzt hier eigentlich gucken.
If,
Alter, rückt nicht komisches Zeug für mich ein, Visual Studio, wenn ich das nicht will.
So, if Debugger ist attached,
dann machen wir das, was ich jetzt gleich da hinschreibe.
Else,
machen wir das.
Pass.
So.
Wenn der Debugger attached ist,
dann surfen wir, ähm,
dann surfen wir, ne, pass, muss man sagen.
Path.
Ja, das ist doch Directory.
Genau, so.
Und dann ist der auch, ähm,
Physical File Provider.
Ist es dann.
Und dann wollen wir allerdings nicht,
nicht das hier haben, sondern,
wobei, kann man sagen, dass er das kopiert?
Copy always.
Das müsste eigentlich jetzt funktionieren.
Warum hast du dich für C Sharp entschieden, weil es ein Windows-only Programm ist?
Wobei, wir müssen,
mal kurz gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Also jetzt ist der Debugger attached.
Starten wir den Krempel.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Das heißt,
ich kann das jetzt hier editieren,
wenn ich das jetzt hier editiere,
also, sagen wir mal, es ist irgendwie, was weiß ich, wie,
wenn ich das jetzt hier editiere, mal irgendwas Offensichtliches.
Schreiben wir hier rein, äh,
keine Ahnung, Hallo oder so.
Hallo.
Ah, ne, ich muss, fuck,
ich habe zu viele Memes gemappt.
Das kann ich nicht mehr speichern.
Sagen wir mal, wenn ich das jetzt speicher,
Hallo, okay, das funktioniert, sehr nice.
Das ist gut.
Dann kann ich das jetzt nicht mehr speichern.
Dann kann ich das nämlich da drin editieren.
Sehr nice.
Ähm, ich muss jetzt nochmal die Memes
anmappen.
Das geht ja auch live mittlerweile.
Das war Steuerung S, muss ich
anmappen, in hier.
Ach, fuck, es ist geladen.
Scheiße.
Okay, ich mach nochmal aus.
Das kann ich ja nämlich direkt drin editieren und ausprobieren.
Da geht das viel besser.
Es gab doch auch irgendwo so ne,
Jaja.
so ein Browser-Plugin,
wo man, wo man den Browser
automatisch reloaden lassen konnte,
wenn sich ein File ändert.
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern?
Ich hab ja irgendwann verwendet.
Das wäre, oder,
das, wat? Ich hab das gelöscht.
Ah, ne, der kopiert das ja immer.
Grrrr.
Lol.
Piss dich. Ähm.
Wir machen, komm, scheiß drauf.
Wir machen das, nachdem es ja eh nur zum entwickeln ist.
Wir sagen jetzt einfach hier, zack.
Das Verzeichnis
mit der Index HTML.
Gut ist.
Da müssen wir gar keinen Geschiss mehr machen.
Geht ja einfach nur, dass wir schneller sind.
Ähm.
Kennt ihr das so von Angular?
Ne, ich hab irgendein Browser-Plugin mal gesehen, da ging das.
So.
Ähm.
Start.
Okay. Ähm.
Den hässlichen Rahmen müssen wir jetzt nämlich noch wegmachen.
Dann probieren wir das jetzt mal mit CSS-Variablen aus.
Und dann können wir auch direkt
hier drin editieren.
Genau.
Na, wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich jetzt hier
probieren wir mal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Irgendwie.
Ah, blablabla.
Alter. Ich hab wieder diese scheiß
Dinger gemappt, ey.
Okay, das klappt.
Nice. Okay.
Gut. Ähm.
Also, Dark Mode haben wir am Start.
Mit so nem hässlichen Button hier oben.
Das sind hier Ctrl-S.
Weg.
Piss dich.
Okay, ähm.
So, was wollt man denn jetzt schönes machen?
Genau, ich wollte, ich wollte dieses CSS-Gedöns nochmal ausprobieren.
Mit, mit, mit diesem
CSS-Variablen.
Also, wie ging das nochmal?
Minus, minus, Dark.
Und dann konnte man sagen.
Meinst du sowas wie LiveJS? Ja, kann schon sein.
Die Rahmen entfernen. Ja, genau.
Die Rahmen will ich entfernen.
Ich will das jetzt nicht überall neu schreiben.
Also, Dark
BG.
Das war jetzt.
Lol.
Strg-C.
Bei Dark BG. Anzeige ist raus.
So.
WeQ Chat. WeQ.
Okay, Strg-C geht nicht. Das muss ich löschen.
Strg-C brauch ich zu oft.
Wo ist es denn? Da.
Come on, bruh. Okay.
Ähm.
So, Dark.
Und dann sagen wir Dark. Machen wir hier Dark BG.
Light.
Light BG.
Light BG ist, ähm.
Oh, guck mal.
Die haben mittlerweile sogar einen Color Picker drinnen.
Also, man muss echt sagen.
Ich meine, das geht mit allen anderen Editoren auch, ja.
Aber man muss echt sagen, Microsoft hat sich da schon Gedanken
beigemacht.
Okay, an sich funktioniert es noch.
Wir haben es ja auch noch irgendwo eingesetzt.
Und dann war.
Und dann Dark BG.
Und dann hier.
War. Habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Light BG.
Funktioniert immer noch.
Sehr schön. Sehr, sehr nice.
Gut. Ähm.
Genau. Und jetzt machen wir die Rahmen
hier weg.
Eigentlich wollen wir gar keine Rahmen. Kann man das sagen?
Kann man irgendwie sagen, gar keine Rahmen?
Gucken, wie es dann aussieht.
Ich meine.
Ehrlich gesagt nicht genau, warum das, äh.
Ich weiß zwar nicht genau,
warum das so ist, aber ich finde, das ist ein guter Effekt.
Schwarz, Weiß, Schwarz, Weiß.
Weil eigentlich wollen wir die, die, die
Rahmen ja immer die gleiche Farbe haben, ne.
Also sprich, ähm.
Das heißt, wir würden
das jetzt wie machen?
Semantisch korrekt, ich würde das BG weglassen.
Joa. Naja, nicht unbedingt.
Weil es könnte doch auch sein,
dass, ähm.
Ich quasi, dass das der dunkle BG ist.
Und ich könnte ja auch sowas hier machen.
Wenn das für den, wenn das für den dunklen BG ist.
Und das, ähm, das ist dann quasi für den
dunklen
So, ne.
Also, falls es
eine andere Farbe wäre.
So hast du natürlich recht.
So, weil jetzt ist ja im Prinzip
beim Dark Mode die Color
quasi Light.
So, und hier ist Dark.
Der Orchis Soundtrack ist gerade richtig
dunkel ist jetzt.
Okay, wie bringe ich denn jetzt meinen, meinem Image
bei? Wie bringe ich denn
meinem Image bei, dass der Rahmen
beim Dark Theme
dunkel sein soll?
Wie mache ich denn das jetzt?
Ich meine, klar, ich könnte,
ich könnte sagen, standardmäßig könnte ich sagen,
ist es so?
Ja, stimmt, Leko, stimmt.
Standardmäßig könnte ich jetzt irgendwie sowas sagen,
aber dann switcht das Ganze
ja nix. Warum soll ich,
warum soll ich den Border 0 Pixel machen?
Ach, ich noob.
Jetzt hab,
jetzt haben wir es doppelt
gestartet, ja.
Aber jetzt stimmt es natürlich beim Wide,
beim Wide nicht.
Warum soll ich denn den Border auf 0 machen? Ich will doch den Border
haben. Ich will doch den
Border. Ich will doch den
Border. Ich will den
Border haben, wenn, wenn es aktiv ist.
Ich will den Border haben, wenn
es aktiv ist.
So, wenn es aktiv ist, Border.
Ansonsten will ich halt, wenn es inaktiv
ist, will ich halt nicht, dass man das sieht.
Das heißt, wie bringe ich denn jetzt den,
okay, wahrscheinlich
muss ich einfach hier drinnen sagen,
okay, ähm, hier drinnen muss ich jetzt wahrscheinlich
die,
wir gucken einfach mal in das Code-Pen rein, da hat er das doch
vorhin auch gemacht. Ach so,
guck mal hier, Body Light Mode
Button, also sagt, ich sag jetzt Body Light Mode,
ähm, Body
Dark Mode Image, sag ich
dann. Also, okay.
Also sag ich, Body,
Light, aber die Autovervollständigung,
Vervollständigung ist schon cool.
Äh, Body Light Mode
Image, das heißt, es betrifft alle Images
da unten drunter, wobei das hier eigentlich
Body Dark, Dark Mode ist.
Dark Mode ist so, und dann
haben wir noch Body
Light Mode
Image is
Light. Und du?
Ha!
Schreckt!
It's as fuck. Oh, ne.
Oh, ne.
Warum überschreibt er das jetzt nicht mehr?
Warum überschreibt er das nicht mehr?
Warum überschreibt
er das jetzt nicht mehr? Ich will, wenn's
active ist, dass es überschrieben wird.
Doch nicht, it's as fuck.
Ich will, dass es überschrieben wird, das hat doch vorher wunderbar
funktioniert, warum funktioniert das jetzt nicht?
Das muss doch jetzt irgendwie einer, ein, ein,
das active hat ne geringere,
ach, muss ich dann Ausrufezeichen dahinter machen?
Irgendwie so?
Das geht doch irgendwie, da kann man doch
überschreiben. Siehste, Leute,
it's, ich weiß das doch, ihr müsst mir das gar nicht,
jetzt hab ich schon alles vorher...
Das war aber echt, äh, grad
schöne, ähm...
Ah, ne, siehste, und ich hab's auch noch falsch gemacht.
Ich hab's auch noch falsch gemacht. Siehste, erst mal
hier wichtig tun, dass ich das doch weiß, und dann
noch falsch gemacht.
Also, Body Light Mode, Image active.
Ach so, ja, aber ich will doch, dass es für
beides gilt.
Dahinter?
Ja, wie mach ich denn das jetzt richtig?
Wirklich, ich weiß, ich weiß nicht. Ups.
Ich, ich...
Eigentlich muss ich den mal neu starten,
ich weiß auch nicht, warum das da rumschmackt jetzt.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Allerdings würde ich das schon, äh, gerne
richtig machen, also, also der
Auskernfuchs hat geschrieben, man macht das, ne,
der lekoarzt hat geschrieben, also Body
Light Mode, Image active.
Kann man nicht sowas machen, wie...
Nur mal so, ich weiß nicht,
kann ich nicht sowas sagen?
Body, egal welcher
Mode,
active?
Also, wie auch immer da die
richtige Syntax ist, aber
gibt's sowas?
Nein, ah.
CSS
Wildcard.
Äh, wat?
Body Image
active, okay, das probier ich mal aus.
Bei Sternchen sprichst du alles an.
Ich will ja nicht alles ansprechen, ich will einfach
alle Images unterhalb von Body, also
alle Images
ansprechen, ähm,
egal ob, ob Body jetzt
Light oder Dark ist.
Weil das hier
zählt wohl vor dem hier.
Ich weiß halt nicht so genau, warum, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay.
Ähm, das heißt, jetzt kann ich das important
wegmachen, ne? Irgendwie
kackt das Ding ab, wenn ich das
ändere, das, das, das,
das Index. Ich weiß nicht so genau, warum,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ah, funktioniert! Nice!
Ich weiß nicht,
ich weiß nicht genau, warum.
Aber es funktioniert, sehr, sehr
schön. Nice.
Nice, so nice, so.
So, jetzt haben wir hier oben
ganz viel CSS gewurschtelt.
Nachdem
mir das eh immer abkackt, schmeiß ich das hier
wieder raus.
Debugge attached, draufgeschissen.
Ähm.
Wow, eine Donation.
Ach, das ist scheiße. Ich guck nach. Moment.
Der Sibaro wieder.
Auf WubblosTV
beziehungsweise maxfps.tv
gibt es jetzt
auch die Streams von September 2017
im Archiv. Hab die gestern noch eingetan.
Sehr nice, Sibaro. Also für alle, die
meine Streams
äh, sich angucken
wollen nochmal oder irgendwie was nachgucken wollen
und es nicht
mehr in den Twitch-Votes drin ist,
könnt ihr mit
maxfps.tv beziehungsweise
wubblos.tv direkt
ins Archiv, was da
Sibaro angelegt hat.
ImageBody sollte auch gehen. Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich geht das auch. Aber
solange das auch so geht,
bin ich auch damit zufrieden.
Das ist okay so. Okay.
Nice. Jetzt
orten wir vielleicht noch unseren
Button unten
drunter an, weil ich meine
das sieht schon ein bisschen
kacke aus mit dem Button da oben drauf.
So, mit dem Button unten drunter
ist doch viel besser. Guck mal, jetzt haben wir
sogar ein Dark Theme.
Ist das nicht geil?
Haben wir sogar noch ein Dark Theme.
Lul what?
I'll make a little.
I'll make a little. So, nice.
Ähm, by the way Max, was machst
du beruflich? Das habe ich schon
öfters mir schwer
getan, das im Stream zu
umschreiben. Deswegen müsste ich mir das eigentlich mal aufschreiben.
Ich kümmere mich hauptsächlich
um, genau so wie es der Bar, der, der
Sibaro schreibt, ich kümmere mich
hauptsächlich um unsere Source Code
Repos.
Und um das Erstellen neuer
Versionen von
unserer Software. Beschreiben wir
das mal so. Das Mergen
neuer Features, um
ähm, schon bestehende
Releases mit Hotfixes zu
versorgen. Ähm,
dann gucken,
dass wir einmal im Monat auch ein neues
Release zustande kriegen. Auch
manchmal Merge-Konflikte lösen,
und lange dabei rumdiskutieren.
Also quasi,
wie es der Sibaro geschrieben hat,
der Chief Headmaster of Git Repository
surveillance, surveillance,
genau.
So, ähm,
ich bin damit jetzt eigentlich relativ zufrieden.
Es ist zwar jetzt nicht
super schick. Wisst ihr, was ein richtig geiler
Effekt wäre? Ähm,
wenn man
das
jeweils, aber da müssen wir mal gucken.
Das, das kriege ich sowas nicht gebacken.
Wenn man das jeweils
ausgewählte Meme dann quasi im Hintergrund,
im Hintergrund quasi
halbtransparent zu sehen würde.
Das machen wir
irgendwann anders.
Was hältst, was hältst du von
Bamboo? Man muss sich mal überlegen, Bamboo ist,
ist diese Atlassian, äh,
Continuous Integration
Geschwubbel, ne? Wer mergt
montags der Azubi? Keiner.
Montags mergt keiner.
Ich hab noch, ich hab noch jemand, der, ähm,
mich dabei unterstützt. Das heißt, es wäre
theoretisch Montag einer da, aber normalerweise
wird montags nicht gemergt.
Montags ist Merch-freier Tag bei uns.
Bin ich nicht da. Bin nicht
gemergt. Ist halt so.
Kann man nichts machen.
Montags können die Leute ordentlich programmieren
und dienstags kann ich's dann merchen.
Weil, und so blöd das jetzt klingt, also
das ist gar nicht, fällt mir jetzt gerade ein, so blöd ist das
gar nicht, dass montags nicht gemergt wird, weil
ähm,
das ist dann ein Tag, wo die Leute motiviert sind
und was machen.
Und oftmals ist es so, dass
das haben wir ganz oft, dass quasi
der Entwickler quasi
sagt, er ist fertig
und reicht das dann quasi
für das nächste Release als
Merch-Request oder Pull-Request, wie es bei GitHub heißt,
ein. Und
allerdings im Laufe des nächsten
halben Tages, so bis Tages,
fällt ihm dann halt trotzdem auf,
da fehlt noch was.
Das kommt ziemlich oft vor.
Deswegen ist das eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht, dass man
einen Merch-freien Tag in der Woche hat,
dass die Leute, wenn sie ja montags eh super motiviert
sind schon, also
vielleicht, ja, dass
die dann auch mal Zeit haben, sich das anzugucken.
Bis Dienstag Nachmittag, so.
Bis ich dann
anfange mit dem Kram.
Das ist eigentlich so, im Nachhinein betrachtet ist
es gar nicht so schlecht zu sagen, ein Tag die Woche
wird nix gemergt. So.
Haben wir noch irgendwas?
Also wir haben jetzt
ein schönes, ein schönes Webfrontend, wir müssen das ganze
müssen wir noch pushen. Ja, das müssen wir noch machen.
Pushen das ganze klein noch.
Ähm.
Haben wir noch irgendwas schönes?
Ich mein, das Play-Symbol sieht nicht so
nicht so toll aus, aber das ist ja eh so
ein geripptes Icon.
Ich bin damit jetzt eigentlich relativ zufrieden für heute.
Für das, dass ich eigentlich keine Ahnung von JavaScript und CSS
und Gedöns hab. Ähm.
Ich mein, es ist deutlich hübscher
als vorher. Es ist immer noch
genauso schnell.
Außer wenn er, ihr habt's grad gesehen, wenn er das erste Mal
ein Bild lädt, dann ist es
ist es lahm. Aber er muss das Bild auch erst
mal einlesen. Danach ist es schnell.
Wenn er's einmal geladen hat.
Das ist kein Icon.
Serious, Max.
Das Shortcut kannst du weglassen.
Oh ja, mal gucken. Vielleicht, nee.
Nee, das ist kein Icon. Das ist
nen, das ist nen Bild.
Warum dauert das eigentlich so lange,
die Wubblos-TV-Seite zu laden? Wahrscheinlich, weil
das der Sebaho auf irgendeinem Free-Hosting
sonst was laufen hat.
Aber die Videos sind schnell
dafür. Und der Traffic wahrscheinlich billig.
Aber man kann.
Kann man?
Kann man echt Bilder inverten?
Echt jetzt? Okay, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ja, klar.
Was weiß ich?
Keine Ahnung, dass das geht.
Ist das nice?
Ja, ist ja gut.
Ja, ihr wisst das ja alle. Dann ist ja gut.
Dann machen wir das.
Also es heißt, ähm
Wie machen wir das jetzt?
Genau.
So.
Okay, dann müssen wir das doch
Moment, wartet mal kurz.
Äh, wie mache ich
denn das jetzt gescheit?
Weil ich will ja nur
Ich will ja nur das hier.
Na gut, dann braucht das ne extra Class
Irgendwie, ne?
Oder?
Wobei, nee.
Doch. Nee.
Class TTS.
So. Okay, probieren wir mal
ob das theoretisch funktioniert.
Okay, wie soll das ganze jetzt gehen?
Moment.
Okay, okay, okay. Also heißt
jetzt, wenn soll
Also es heißt Filter Invert
Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich, weil das
bei WebKit mal wieder anders, warum
Warum heißt das bei WebKit anders?
Bei Apple?
Warum ist das bei Apple wieder anders?
Also sagen wir
Filter Invert. Machen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Soll das halt standardmäßig dann
Nö, da invertet sich nix.
Ach nee, das ist ja nur wenns
Active ist.
Ha! Funktioniert!
Allerdings will ich ja nur das
Image Inverten.
Ich will nur das Image Inverten, nicht den Rahmen
drum herum. Das ist dann doch nicht so einfach, oder?
Was kann man machen,
wenn man seinen Monitor durchs Draufhauen zerstört hat?
Ich würde sagen, einen neuen Monitor kaufen.
Da wird es nicht so viele Möglichkeiten geben.
Also
wenn die Scheibe kaputt ist, ist es kaputt halt.
Ne?
Und bei einem
LCD ist halt auch nicht nur Scheibe kaputt,
da ist halt auch Kristalle kaputt und
Zeugs kaputt. Da kannst du
ja wahrscheinlich nur neu erkaufen.
Ori hat echt
einen nicen Soundtrack. Ein nicer Soundtrack
ist das.
Kannst du nicht auf dein RGB von Imageglas zugreifen?
Bestimmt irgendwie.
Aber das ist mir eigentlich zu, ähm...
Welcher Rahmen? Der hier.
Der Rahmen wird invertet.
Vom Image.
Ach, so meinst du das?
Du meinst, dass man quasi sagt, ähm...
Also, dass man quasi
sowas machen würde, wie...
Wo ist es denn hier?
Dass man quasi nicht nur...
Dass man hier noch eine andere Klasse dazu macht,
also irgendwie sowas, was ich... Plupp!
Und dann sagt man quasi...
Bin ich mal gespannt, ob das
klappt. Dann sagt man
quasi hier...
Word 1, plupp.
Oder? Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Nee, geht nicht.
Egal.
Egal, funktioniert nicht. Macht nix.
Da muss ich noch was anderes ausdenken, aber
das ist schon mal ganz nice, so wie es jetzt ist.
Ich lösch den Krempel hier jetzt mal wieder.
Nee, ich brauch ne Border Color.
Erstens springen die Bilder sonst doof rum.
Und ich will's ja markieren mit, ähm...
Ich will ja einen Rahmen
drumherum machen, wenn's aktiv ist.
Also ich
brauch nen Border, wenn's aktiv ist. Zum Beispiel, wenn's
aktiv ist, soll's grün sein.
Die Border Color mitinvertieren.
Ja.
Ey, das ist doof.
Quasi verkehrt mitgeben, damit sie richtig ver...
Das würde wahrscheinlich
funktionieren, ja?
Ich kann dir diesen Mix
empfehlen zum Programmieren. Aha.
Das hören wir uns
jetzt gleich mal an.
Ori Soundtrack ist eh fertig.
MonkaS.
Ach, das ist nen...
Das kenn ich.
Das ist... Die haben noch viel mehr
Sachen remixed. Das ist nice.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber man muss halt sagen, dass
Majora's Mask Soundtrack halt
ziemlich
MonkaS ist.
Das find ich nicht entspannend. Der ist eher schon so ein bisschen gruselig.
Hör ich das mal an?
So übelst MonkaS
Soundtrack.
So, das lassen wir jetzt erstmal
mit dem Border so. Ich mein, ich bin hier...
Wie gesagt, ich bin über dieses JavaScript-Geschwubbel
hier eh nicht so ganz glücklich drinnen.
Das ist voll MonkaS, das Soundtrack.
Das... Oh.
Das ist, wenn man...
Ja, Tommy, das hatte ich
gerade so. Das hat doch nicht funktioniert.
Ich hatte eben ne extra
Klasse für das Invert.
Das war bei mir nicht geschachtelt. Ach so.
Boah, nee.
Das wird mir zu komplizier...
Ich muss schnell mal ein bisschen...
Gedanken machen. Vielleicht machen wir
das Ganze auch mit irgendeinem krassen,
trendigen JavaScript-
Framework. Da muss man den ganzen Krempel nicht
von Hand
machen. Zumindest nicht
so extrem von Hand machen. Man muss halt dazu sagen,
ich hab
außer nem Vue.js-Tutorial
hab ich mir da noch nicht allzu viel angeguckt.
Das ist ja auch nicht
so kompliziert, was wir machen.
Aber es ist doch gar nicht so übel.
Ich find das schon ganz nice.
Was? Musst ihr mal
p5.js angucken?
Was ist p5.js?
JavaScript-Frameworks
gibt's ja quasi...
Ach so, das ist
irgendeine Grafik-Geschichte. Okay.
Guck mal, das ist so
kaputt, dass man nicht mal scrollen kann, die Seite.
So viel zum Thema JavaScript, ne?
Null.
Also wahrscheinlich block ich hier irgendwas drauf.
Nö.
Ich kann nicht mal mal scrollen! Auf der
Seite.
Oh, da gibt's hier gar nichts. Man kann
nix scrollen und nix markieren. Ich hasse
solche Seiten, Leute. Ich hasse solche
JavaScript-Seiten, die meinen Browser kaputt
machen, ey. Guck mal,
da kann ich's auch mal anklicken.
Oh, das benutze ich nicht.
So. Gut. Gibt's
jetzt noch irgendwas, was wir machen wollen, Leute?
Also...
Ich push das
gleich, wenn wir hier fertig sind noch.
Ist der Text ne Grafik?
Welcher Text?
Achso, der Text da drauf.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich. Wobei ich mich halt
frage... Ne, ist es nicht.
Es ist... Was weiß ich, was das ist? Keine Ahnung.
Es ist... JavaScript
bis zum Umfallen, ey. Es ist...
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist mir zu viel JavaScript-Skripte
auf der Seite.
Okay. Ja, ich würde sagen,
an der Stelle
gehen wir das nächste Mal weiter.
Ich uploade das Ganze jetzt auch.
Wir brauchen auch noch unbedingt
eine Stimmenauswahl
für Text-to-Speech.
Weil aktuell
kann das ja nur
Microsoft
George ist es, glaube ich.
Warte mal, Leute, wir gucken noch mal kurz,
was es für Stimmen zur Auswahl gibt.
Also, wir haben zur Auswahl...
Ähm...
Ich muss mal kurz auf Konsole umstellen, da ich was sehe.
Also, wir haben zur Auswahl an Stimmen...
Wir testen mal, was es da für
Stimmen für gibt.
Ähm... Haben wir hier irgendwo
zwischendrin? Also, wir haben
Voice, irgendwas mit Voice.
Installed
Voices.
Voice Info Name.
So,
lassen wir uns das mal ausgeben, was es für
Voices gibt.
Also, wir haben David,
Hazel und
Kira.
Da lassen wir die doch mal
labern.
Machen wir Test Text-to-Speech
mit allen Stimmen.
Wobei...
Man kann sich das hier nicht...
Das kann man sich hier doch...
Ne, man kann sich
das auch hier...
Also, das ist David.
Den kennen wir schon.
Machen wir Hazel.
Nein.
Und dann haben wir Cira.
Dann noch...
Also, die anderen habe ich wohl nicht installiert.
Keine Ahnung, die habe ich zumindest nicht zur Auswahl.
Ich muss sagen,
da ist David noch
am besten, oder?
Da ist David noch
am besten. Der Rest ist ja ganz
grausam.
Wollen wir zusätzliche Schriften eigentlich installieren?
Äh, nicht Schriften.
Zusätzliche Voices.
Install
Voice.
Die ganzen Weeps unter uns.
Get more
Microsoft Texte.
Ja, okay, wie kann man jetzt...
Das ist auch wieder so super kompliziert bei Microsoft alles.
Warum kann man hier nicht einfach
eine neue
Sprache hinzufügen?
You can download some voices
from free TTS, was?
Free Text to Speech.
Ah!
Von der Seite lade ich mir nichts runter.
Das sieht schon...
Ne.
Ich will keine Web-API verwenden
für Text to Speech.
Da müsste man den Krams ja jedes Mal quasi online schicken
und dann wieder
wieder empfangen und dann abspielen.
Das wird auch wahrscheinlich viel zu viel
laggen quasi.
Da brauchst du ja immer eine halbe Sekunde, bis es losgeht.
Windows 10
Voice.
Weep.
Wir brauchen eine Weep-Stimme.
TTS.
Ah, das hängt davon ab, was für eine Sprache man
ins Thema lagt.
Ich hab's ja nur...
Ich krieg wahrscheinlich nur die Sprachen angezeigt
für Englisch jetzt.
Ich hab David.
David...
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Cute Text to Speech Guide.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich muss an dem Ding aber noch beibringen,
das lässt das Tool durch die Decke gehen,
wenn es Anime Weep
Voice drin hat zum Vorlesen.
Das muss ja
streamtauglich sein, weil ich mein,
das ist langweilig, ne?
Ich mein, Microsoft David ist langweilig.
Also, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall noch zwei weitere Stimmen.
Wir brauchen einmal
so eine ultramännliche
Stimme, die das Ganze vorliest.
Aber einmal noch.
Und dann brauchen wir noch, ähm...
Dann brauchen wir noch irgendeine Weep-Stimme.
Und dann brauchen wir noch irgendwie so eine
Craygasm-Stimme.
Oh, megaloll.
So was in der Richtung brauchen wir noch.
Das kommt immer gut an, solche Sachen.
Ja.
Ich muss mal ein paar Text to Speech Sachen
raussuchen und wahrscheinlich
müssen wir dann auch irgendeine andere Text to Speech
Library verwenden, anstatt die...
Was? Probier mal...
Hapu-Software.
Was soll
ne Weep-Stimme sein?
Moment.
Wer hat, äh, wer hat ein gutes Beispiel für ne
super, äh,
super Beispielstimme?
Okay, Hapu-Software.
Muss das Text to Speech sein?
Ja, klar muss das Text to Speech sein, weil ich will ja,
ähm...
Ich will ja hier ein Textpfeil hinlegen,
wo ich den Text reinschreibe,
den er vorlesen soll.
Also, ich will ja da reinschreiben,
was ich will.
Find your voice. Language.
Japanese.
Brand.
Egal.
Female.
Moment, ich will das nicht kaufen.
Ich will das nicht
kaufen.
Text to Speech Guide. Oh.
Das brauchen wir.
Das sind Sachen, die will ich hier nicht on-stream aufmachen.
Ich weiß nicht, was da, was da passiert.
Wenn ich da drauf gehe.
Das muss man einbauen, unbedingt.
Hahaha.
Das schaut man dann schlecht.
Ich muss mal gucken, was es da für Text to Speech
Sachen gibt. Okay.
Das muss ich mal aber dann off-stream gucken.
Ich trau mich hier nicht, on-stream die ganzen Seiten aufzumachen.
Was gibt's denn so für, für...
Mary?
Ja, muss ich mal, muss ich mal
off-stream gucken, was es da so alles gibt.
Max, du hast doch sicher nicht
überall LAN-Kabel verlegt.
Denkst du, dass man 30 Meter Kabel bedenkenlos
verlegen kann, ohne... Ja, klar.
Klar. 30 Meter Kabel.
30 Meter Kabel ist überhaupt kein Ding.
30 Meter Kabel, brauchst du nicht mal gute Kabel
für Gigabit.
Da kannst du wahrscheinlich die letzte Krütze verlegen
bei 30 Meter.
Ne, es können keine Soundfiles sein, weil ich will
da reinschreiben, was er, was er vorliest.
Von KS Sounds.
Okay, Leute.
Ich geh jetzt was futtern.
Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Da merkt man, dass das der Zelda Soundtrack ist.
Also ein Remix.
Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Ähm...
Ich guck mal off-stream,
was es da so für
Voice-Geschichten noch gibt.
Was ist Hex War?
Was war dir klar?
Hex for CS GO.
Natürlich dann.
Bester Name
wieder.
Streamst du heute noch? Ich streame gerade.
Ähm, ne, heute nicht mehr.
Du kommst in den Stream,
ist es vorbei. Ja, ich muss ja auch mal irgendwann was essen.
Gut, ähm,
ich weiß nicht, ich muss mal, ich guck mal
off-stream, ähm,
was es so für Text-to-Speech-Geschichten
noch gibt.
Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen. Ich push das Ganze jetzt gleich noch.
Macht's gut, bis denn. Tschüss.